bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat hier la Commission
européenne présidé depuis peu par
Jean-Claude Junker a annoncé l'abandon
d'un certain nombre de projets
écologiques pour l'année 2015 pour se
concentrer sur l'emploi en revanche en
France et bien l'environnement va rester
une priorité pour l'année prochaine
notamment parce que la France accueille
à la fin de l'année le grand sommet de
Paris sur le climat un sommet qui
rassemblera plus de 190 pays qui ont
pour objectif de parvenir à un véritable
accord contraignant en matière de
réduction des émissions des gaz à effet
de serre François Hollande a d'ailleurs
appelé il y a peu à un véritable accord
historique en la matière dans ce cadre
et bien l'objectif du projet de loi
examiné ce matin par les sénateurs et de
prolonger les effets du protocole de
Kyoto de 2013 à 2000 202 en effet cet
accord qui a été conclu en
1997 est le seul accord juridiquement
contraignant qui existe aujourd'hui en
matière de réduction des gaz à effet de
serre il prévoyait à l'époque et bien
que les parties engagé réduis de 5 % les
réductions de 6 gaz à effet de serre de
2008 à 2012 par rapport au niveau de
1990 alors prolonger ce protocole de
Kyoto en attendant le grand sommet de
Paris donc bien l'objectif de ce texte
ce texte qui a été adopté de façon assez
consensuelle à l'Assemblée nationale
alors que va-t-il en être au Sénat
réponse avec
l'hémicycle maintenant que tout le monde
est installé donc je donne la parole à
Monsieur Thierry Mandon secrétaire
d'État chargé de la réforme de l'État et
de la
simplification vous avez la parole
monsieur le
ministre merci Monsieur le prés
président madame la rapporteur mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs le protocole de
Kyoto est aujourd'hui le seul
instrument international juridiquement
contraignant de réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre il met en effet
en œuvre la convention cadre des Nations
Unies sur les changements climatiques de
1992 qui fixe les grandes orientations
de la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique après son adoption en 97 je
crois et son entrée en vigueur en 2005
le protocole de Kyoto a permis de
réduire les émissions des pays
développés durant une première période
d'application de 2008 à 2012 vous le
savez le gouvernement français est
totalement mobilisé pour lui trouver un
accord successeur qui pourrait être
adopté en tout cas c'est c'est le vœux
et le sens de l'action de la France à
Paris en décembre 2015 lors de la 21e
conférence des nations- Unies sur le
climat plus connu encore que sous le nom
la de la COP
21 ce nouvel accord devra être
applicable à tous les émetteurs et
entrerait en vigueur en 2020 il est donc
absolument impératif que l'action
internationale en faveur de la protction
notre climat se poursuive entre la fin
de la période du protocole de Kyoto en
2012 et l'entrée en vigueur de ce que
nous espérons être l'accord de Paris en
2020 c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
débattons aujourd'hui du
projet de
loi inscrit à l'ordre du jour de de
votre assemblée ce projet
autorise en effet la ratification de
l'amendement de 2A au protocole de Kyoto
cet amendement adopté en décembre 2012
prévoit une 2e période d'engagement de
2013 à 2020 afin de prolonger les
efforts de réduction des émissions il
fait partie de l'équilibre politique
trouvé en 2011 lors de la conférence sur
le climat de Durban c'est la promesse
d'engagement dans une deème période du
protocole de Kyoto qui a pour beaucoup
ouvert la voie à l'élaboration d'un
nouvel accord universel sur le clim
tel qu'il est adopté cet amendement est
conforme aux positions de la France et
des autres membres de l'Union européenne
qu'il parle il faut le souligner d'une
seule voix lors des discussions
internationales sur le climat l'Union
européenne s'est en effet doté d'un
paquet énergie climat en 2008 dont l'un
des objectifs est de réduire de 20 % les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
2020 par rapport au niveau de 90
l'objectif européen fixé pour la 2è
période du protocole de Kyoto découle
directement de celui contenu dans ce
paquet énergie climat c'est la raison
pour laquelle l'Union européenne s'est
engagé à mettre en œuvre l'amendement
dès le 1er janvier 2013 sans attendre
son entrée en vigueur tout port à croire
d'ailleurs que l'objectif que s'est fixé
l'Union européenne à l'horizon 2020
pourra être atteint voire dépasser
puisque ces émissions ont d'ors et déjà
été réduites de 18 % sur un objectif de
20 % je l'ai rappelé précédemment
d'autres partenaires ont également
proposé un objectif de réduction de le
émissions pour la période 2013-2020
l'Australie la Biélorussie le Kazakhstan
le lchenstein le Monaco la Norvège la
Suisse l'Ukraine mais le Canada qui a
décidé de se retirer du protocole en
2011 la Russie le Japon la
Nouvelle-Zélande n'ont pas souhaité se
réengager les États-Unis sont également
restés en retrait puisque il faut le
rappeler il n'ont jamais ratifié ce
protocole le groupe d'experts
intergouvernementale sur l'évolution du
climat vient de nous rappeler l'urgence
à agir si vous nous voulons limiter
l'augmentation de la température
mondiale en dessous de 2°gr par rapport
au niveau préindustriel cette deuxième
période ne couvrant que 15 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre vous
devinerez aimment qu'elle ne permet pas
à elle seule de faire face au défis
climatiqu mais de nombreux pays se sont
fixés des objectifs en dehors de ce
cadre et notamment les États-Unis la
Nouvelle-Zélande les pays émergent et
bien que cette deuxième période soit
imparfaite d'un point de vue climatique
elle joue un rôle de transition
essentielle élaborer un nouvel accord
avec 195 pays nécessite du temps et
puisque le temps a manqué en 2009 à
copenhag pour parvenir à l'adoption d'un
successeur au protocole de Kyoto il doit
continuer à s'appliquer jusque l'accord
de Paris entre en vigueur l'abandon de
cet instrument et le vide juridique qui
aurait automatiquement entraîné qui
aurait automatiquement entraîné aurait
été perçu comme un recul de la
communauté
internationale par ailleurs cette deuxè
période nous permet de continuer à
accumuler expérience sur les outils de
mise en œuvre des politiques climatiques
cela est vrai s'agissant des mécanismes
de marché prévus par le protocole cela
est vrai s'agissant des règles de suivi
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
puisque l'amendement de DOA rappelons-le
ajoute un 7è gaz à ceux déjà couverts
par le Protocole de Kyoto le trio trio
tri pardon excusez-moi trifluorure
d'azote et non le moindre puisque le
pouvoir de ce gaz de réchauffement est
17000 fois supérieure à celui du CO2 il
convient également de noter que
l'amendement introduit en mécanisme de
révision des engagements de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
pour les rendre plus ambitieux en cours
de période en raison de la faible
participation ce mécanisme pourrait ne
pas être utilisé mais il est néanmoins
susceptible de nous inspirer pour ce que
nous espérons être l'accord de 2015 la
ratification de l'amendement au niveau
européen est un processus long puisque
30 instruments de ratification doivent
être assemblés avant que nous ne les
déposions en même temps auprès du
Secrétaire général des Nations unies
tous les États-membres de l'Union
européenne doivent en effet mener leur
processus de ratification au niveau
national l' l'Islande a fait le choix
rappelons-le de prendre un engagement
conjoint avec ses partenaires de l'Union
européenne et une décision du Conseil
relative à la conclusion de l'amendement
de DOA et à l'exécution conjointe des
engagements qui en découlent est en
cours de négociation à Bruxelles
certaines réticences ont été formulées
par la Pologne que nous nous efforçons
actuellement de dépasser dans la
perspective de notre présidence de la
Conférence sur le climat de 2015 il est
essentiel que l'amendement au protocole
de Kyoto soit ratifié dans les meilleurs
délais pour envoyer un signal positif
sur la mise en œuvre des engagements
tout comme la capitalisation du fond
vert pour le climat est une véritable
attente des pays vulnérables la
ratification de la amendement est une
demande forte à laquelle nous devons
répondre en autorisant cette
ratification vous contribuerez donc à
favoriser la confiance entre les États
cette confiance qui est un des facteurs
clés du succès de Cop 21 tels sont
monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs les principales observations
qu'appelle l'amendement au protocole
Kyoto qui fait l'objet du projet de loi
aujourd'hui proposé à votre approbation
merci monsieur le ministre ministre la
parole est à Madame lailla Aichi
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées vous avez la parole ma cher
collègue monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues nous examinons
aujourd'hui l'amendement au protocole de
Kyoto du 11 décembre
1997 qui a été adopté à DOA le 8
décembre 2012 après de longues et
difficiles négociations
je vais tout d'abord aborder rapidement
le protocole de Kyoto puisque
l'amendement de DOA se présente comme la
poursuite de celui-ci pour la période
2013 20020 le protocole de Kyoto je vous
le rappelle fait suite à la convention
cadre des nations- Unies sur les
changements climatiques adopté à New
York en 1992 par 154 états et entré en
vigueur le 21 mars
1994 il a été adopté lors de la 3e
Conférence des partis au COP 3 au Japon
en novembre 1997 il renforce les
engagements pris par les pays développés
en vue de réduire le réchauffement
planétaire d'origine humaine
entrer en vigueur le 16 16 février 2005
il ne porte que sur la période
2008-22 toutefois le protocole de Kyoto
se présente comme le seul instrument
international juridiquement contraignant
permettant de limiter la hausse de la
température mondiale en dessous de 2°gr
celus par rapport au niveau
préindustriel il vise à réduire ou
limiter les émissions de six gaz à effet
provenant des secteurs de l'énergie des
procédés industriels de l'utilisation
des solventss de l'agriculture et des
déchets il contient un objectif global
de réduction du total des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre d'au moins 5 % par
rapport à l'année 1990 et des
engagements chiffrés pour les pays
développés qui les ont acceptés selon le
principe des responsabilités communes
mais différencié de la convention 4 des
Nations Unies sur le changement
climatique seul les pays développés en
raison de leur responsabilités
historique et les pays en transition
vers une économie de marché ceux de
l'ancien bloc de l'Est ont des
engagements chiffrés pardon à l'époque
l'Union européenne des 15 s'est ainsi
engagé à réduire collectivement ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 8 %
par rapport à l'années 1990 tandis que
les États-Unis n'ont jamais ratifié ce
protocole le Canada que lui qui lui
avait ratifié en 2002 a annoncé sa
volonté de se désengager en décembre
2011 avec effet l'année suivante les
grands pays voie de développement comme
la Chine et l'Inde n'y ont pas pris part
tout comme le protocole de Kyoto
l'amendement de DOA est le résultat de
longues négociations en effet dès 2007
le plan d'action de Bali a décidé dans
un cadre de négociation en prévision de
la fin de la période d'engagement de
Kyoto mais la COP 15 réunie à Copenhague
en 2009 s'est soldée par un échec et n'a
pas permis d'aboutir à un nouvel accord
international ce n'est donc qu'en 2011
que la COP 17 réunie à durbane est
parvenu à un accord accord prévoyant
notamment la conclusion au plus tard en
2015 d'un accord mondial sur les
changements climatiques sous réserve de
la souscription par les pays développés
d'une deuxième période d'engagement dans
le cadre du protocole de Kyoto à
comptter du 1er janvier 2013 sur le
modèle du protocole de Kyoto
l'amendement de DOA prévoit un objectif
global de réduction du total des
émissions des gaz à effet de serre d'au
moins 18 % par rapport à l'année 1990
ainsi que les nouveaux engagement de
réduction chiffré d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre souscrit par les États
partis qui les ont acceptés mais qui
sont moins nombreux qu'au cours de
l'année la première période le Japon et
la Russie notamment ont refusé de
s'engager à nouveau au total les pays
engagés dans cette deuxème période ne
sont responsables que de 15 % des
émissions mondiales de gaz à effet de
serre ce qui donne à l'amendement de DOA
une portée finalement assez modeste
c'est peu mais c'est mieux que rien
l'amendement de DOA contient également
un mécanisme de révision
du niveau d'ambition sans lesquels la
seconde période du protocole de de Kyoto
n'aurait vraisemblablement pas pu être
adoptée à DOA il s'agit d'une procédure
simplifiée qui permet une adoption et
une mise en œuvre rapide des nouveaux
objectifs sans nouvelle ratification une
première table ronde ministérielle a
d'ailleurs eu lieu à bonne le 5 juin
2014 elle n'a toutfois pas permis de
relever les engagements des pays
développés comme le demandent de manière
constante les pays en développement le
clivage Nord-Sud a bien failli
d'ailleurs se révéler fatale à la COP 20
de l'IMA qui vient de s'achever de
nombreuses heures de négociations
supplémentaires ont été nécessaires pour
allier un certain nombre de pays en
développement qui s'opposaient au
premier texte présenté le principe de
responsabilité commune mais différencié
et les capacités respectives ainsi que
la nécessité pour les pays développés
d'augmenter leur soutien financier à
l'égard des pays en développement ont
été réaffirmés dans la décision finale
l'amendement de DOA règle également la
délicate question des surplus de quotas
des missission par rapport aux émissions
réelles ou airchaud accordé aux pays en
transition pendant la première période
afin de relancer l'économie il a été
décidé que les quotas accordés en
seconde période ne peuvent pas dépasser
la moyenne des émissions nationales sur
la période 2008 2010 voici donc
sommairement exposé l'essentiel du
contenu de l'amendement de DOA de fait
cet amendement vous l'aurez compris est
un amendement de transition à haute
portée symbolique c'est un amendement de
transition parce qu'il permet la
poursuite du protocole de Kyoto sur la
période
2013-2020 il comble le vide juridique
entre la fin du protocole de Kyoto en
2012 et l'entrée en vigueur prévu en
2020 d'un nouvel accord mondial sur le
climat celui-ci devrait être conclu sous
l'égide de la convention 4 des Nations
Unies sur le changement climatique lors
de la COP 21 qui se réunir à Paris en
décembre 2015 c'est une étape qui
s'inscrit dans la politique climatique
de l'Union européenne et de la France
l'engagement de l'Union européenne et de
ses états- membres d'une réduction des
gaz à effet de serre de moins de 20 %
par rapport à 1990 correspond aux
objectifs définis dans le paquet climat
énergie de 2020 d'ailleurs l'Union tout
comme la France a dépassé l'objectif qui
lui était fixé dans la la première
période du protocole de Kyoto et devrait
faire la même de même pour la deuxième
période c'est un amendement à haute
portée symbolique parce qu'il est
parallèle au processus d'élaboration de
l'accord mondial sur le climat il sera
nécessairement à l'ordre du jour de la
COP 21 qui se réunira à Paris en
décembre 2015 la conférence des partis
de la convention CAD des Nations Unies
sur les changements climatiques servant
également de cadre à la réunion des
partis au protocole de Kyoto ce
processus d'élaboration d'un accord
mondial a été relancé par le sommet sur
le climat organisé par le Secrétaire
général des Nations unies à New York le
23 décembre 2014 il est conforté par la
première réunion de capitalisation du
fond vert pour le climat qui vient de se
dérouler à Berlin le 20 novembre 2014 et
qui était très attendu par les pays en
voie de développement 21 pays se sont
engagés à verser 9,3 milliards de
dollars sur la période 2015 2018 la
France y contribue comme vous le savez à
hauteur d'un milliard de dollars ce qui
devrait permettre en on l'espère au fond
vert d'entrer dans sa phase
opérationnelle courant 2015 et d'engager
sa programmation d'ici la cop21 ce qui
sera un signal fort en direction des
pays en
développement pour financer le fond vert
et plus généralement la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique je souhaite à
titre personnel vous proposer une piste
de réflexion je considère qu'il pourrait
être pertinent de s'intéresser davantage
à la dynamique spéculative qui entoure
les cours de Bours et des matières
premières et notamment à leur grande
volatilité en effet les cours de la
bourse sont aujourd'hui dans une très
large mesure déconnecté de l'économie
réelle sachant que plus de la moitié des
ordres passés ne sont jamais exécutés
j'estime qu'une piste serait de taxer
les ordres de bourse non réalisés de
fait une telle taxe même minime sur le
montant de ces de ces transactions
virtuelles permettrait de rationaliser
les comportements des acteurs économique
et financiers concernés et redonner de
la réalité au cours de la bourse
permettant ainsi de mieux les contrôler
mais également de permettre un effet de
levier pour le fond vert dans la
perspective de la conclusion d'un accord
universel sur le climat la France s'est
engagée à appliquer la 2uxè période
d'engagement dès le 1er janvier 2013 et
a ratifié l'amendement au protocole de
Kyoto le plus rap ridement possible elle
a d'ors et déjà pris les mesures
nécessaires à la mise en œuvre de cette
deuxième période d'engagement souscrit
par l'Union européenne et ses
États-membres cette ratification
soulignera ainsi la volonté de la France
de parvenir à un accord mondial sur le
climat dans le prolongement de l'accord
européen conclu en octobre 2014 visant à
réduire de 40 % les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre à l'horizon 2030 et de
l'accord sino-américain signé le 12
novembre dernier la France veut y voir
un encouragement pour le sommet climat
de Paris 2015 alors même que le dernier
rapport du GC publié à Copenhague au
début de ce mois de novembre recommande
d'agir vite la décision finale de la COP
du de liimma qui vient de s'ajever après
avoir joué les prolongations laisse
également auguré d'une chance de succès
puisqu'elle a jeté les bases de la
négociation de l'accord final et a
encadré dans cette perspective les
contributions nationales attendues au
premier trimestre 2015 par ailleurs la
proposition de décision du Conseil comm
2013 768 finale relative à la conclusion
de l'amendement de DOA au protocole de
Kyoto à la CCNUCC et à l'exécution
conjointe des engagements prévoit que
l'Union européenne et ses États membres
doivent déposer les instruments de
ratification au plus tard le 16 février
2015 il est d'autant plus important que
la France autorise cette ratification
qu'il SEM primordial que l'Union
européenne et ses étatsmembres arrivent
Unis au rendez-vous du Bourget dans un
an tout comme il est souhaitable que
l'amendement de DOA entre en vigueur le
plus rapidement possible à la date du 14
novembre 2014 19 états seulement avaient
ratifié l'amendement c'est pourquoi la
commission vous demande d'adopter le
projet de loi autorisant la ratification
de l'amendement au protocole de Kyoto du
11 décembre 1997 je vous remercie merci
ma cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Jérôme Bignon rapporteur pour
avis de la commission du développement
durable
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur monsieur
le Président de la Commission du
développement durable mes chers
collègues quelques mots à mon tour pour
vous donner le l'avis du de la
commission du développement durable qui
s'est saisi avec beaucoup d' propos d'un
d'un texte qui nous concerne tous et qui
s'inscrit bien dans la logique
transversale du développement durable
qui s'intéresse à ces questions nous
revenons quelquesuns au Sénat de de
liima puisque le Sénat a était
représenté par au moins CIN ou six
sénateurs le président de la commission
des affaires économiques le président de
la commission du développement durable
et et quatre autres membres de notre
assemblée où nous avons participer à des
avec des modalités diverses au aux
négociations sur le climat et euh on
peut dire probablement que jamais un
texte de loi n'a été autant d'actualité
que celui cette ratification qui est
véritablement si j'ose dire branché sur
la négociation que nous venons de vivre
monsieur benkimoun en ouvrant le la
convention à traité cinq points et le 5è
c'était demander avec avec insistance
aux nations présentes ou absente mais
néanmoins
représenté de ratifier comme un pH comme
un point symbolique ce qui avait été
souscrit à DOA et qu'on appelle
l'amendement de DOA au protocole de
Kyoto ne serait-ce que pour prolonger
son application jusqu'à 2020 c'est vrai
que l'Union européenne a spontanément et
sans que c'est cette ratification ait
lieu accepté de de prolonger les effets
du protocole mais l'Union européenne est
bien seule par rapport au euh au reste
du monde sur ces sujets-là notamment et
euh il est urgent que avant que ne soit
qu'on rentre fondamentalement dans la
dernière ligne droite de la conférence
de Paris il paraît clair que cette
convention cet amendement de DOA doit
être ratifié alors un mot euh peut-être
sur le les évolution de la de la prise
de conscience sur le réchauffement
climatique très longtemps vous vous en
souvenez puisque c'est un point qui la
prise de conscience du réchauffement
climatique doit remonter dans la
communauté scientifique à une trentaine
d'années
et c'est intéressant de voir que le
cheminement a été long parce que y
compris dans la communauté scientifique
il y a eu des voix divergentes qui ont
sonné qui ont raisonn pendant longtemps
et puis aujourd'hui on peut considérer
qu'après le 5e rapport du GC Le
consensus est arrivé pour dire
que la réalité du phénomène est
indiscutable ou très peu discutable et
en tout cas peu discuté ou plus discuté
et que son origine entropique est
également plus discuté donc la on est
dans une deuxème phase aujourd'hui où la
prise de conscience de l'urgence à agir
et est au cœur de des esprits de ceux
qui s'intéresse à ces questions et cette
prise de conscience est aujourd'hui
davantage collective et davantage répond
endu dans la société civile notamment et
c'est pas notre collègue ronant dant qui
me contredira grâce à cette société
civile qui s'en est emparé et je pense
que c'est le un un point qui est
substantiel dans la dans l'évolution de
la marche vers la la la la solution
technique politique financière au
règlement de ce problème c'est
précisément le fait que la société
civile s'est emparée de ce sujet
aujourd'hui les populations du monde
entier voient les phénomènes climatiques
et ont pris conscience qu'il y avait
probablement quelque chose à faire pour
ne
pas laisser faire au au risque de mettre
en péril beaucoup de choses sur notre
terre alors le le protocole de Kyoto je
ne reviendrai pas en détail dessus
d'abord madame leilla aishi l'a très
bien fait pour dire sauf que ce
protocole est le seul accord mondial qui
soit contraignant et donc ce protocole
de Kyoto qui commence à remonter
puisquil date de 1997
euh il a quelque chose de très
intéressant c'est qu'il a marqué le
point de départ d'un processus itératif
de de conférence
internationale 92 Rio 21 20 fois les le
monde entier s'est réuni pour parler du
climat dans des conférences qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui qu' qu'on peut
qualifier aujourd'hui d'un d'un
processus itératif mais on voit bien que
c'est long pour parvenir à à avancer euh
aujourd'hui il s'agit de mettre d'accord
se mettre d'accord sur l'application de
nouvelles contraintte 190 pays sont plus
de 190 pays je crois 194 sont autour de
la table et alors ce qui est toujours
qu'il faut bien prendre ce dont il faut
bien prendre conscience c'est que ces
pays sont très éloignés les uns des
autres VO le l'extraordinaire processus
de rassemblement de 195 pays dans un
autre pays c'est 20000 personnes qui
sont venues euh à à Lima c'est 40000 qui
sont attendus l'année prochaine à Paris
c'est dire que c'est un espèce de
déplacement de masse qui est
considérable même si les moyens modernes
facilitent ces choses-là et et
deuxièmement la deuxième difficulté
au-delà du nombre des pays c'est
l'extraordinaire différence des pays
vous avez des petits États insulaires
qui sont touchés aujourd'hui par la le
réchauffement climatique ils le vivent
hein je pense par exemple aux Maldives
qu'on met souvent en avant ou de
quelques communautés du Pacifique et
puis vous avez des pays colossalement
riches colossalement développé les
États-Unis pour ne pas les nommer qui
ont un proc qui ont une vision ces
sujets donc il faut arriver à combiner
le le point de vue de T ces états qui
ont des tailles des PIB des populations
des positionnements géographiques
tellement différents que l'autre jour à
la commission j'ai j'aiévoqué la
construction de la tour de Babel euh
quand les hommes se sont mis à
construire la tour de la de Babel nous
dit la Bible c'était très compliqué pour
eux parce qu'ils étaient tellement
nombreux ils parlaient tellement de
langues différentes qu'il n'y arrivaient
pas et là on est dans un processus qui
est de même de même type processus
collectif qui malheureusement pour la
tour de Babel a échoué donc il faut
prendre garde de ne pas de de ne pas
aboutir de ne pas aboutir au même
résultat le bilan de la première période
d'engagement du protocole de Kyoto la
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
étrangères l'a très bien dit et
relativement mitigé les émissions
mondiales ont augmenté de 30 % parce que
entre 90 et 2010 le protocole de
Kyoto plus la réalité des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre il a été conçu pour
retranscrire des engagements de pays
développés qui représentaient en 1997
plus de la moitié des émissions
mondiales et la défection des grands
États comme les États-Unis ou le Canada
ont accentué le décalage entre les
émissions couvertes par le protocole et
les émissions effectivement constaté à
cela il faut ajouter effectivement que
en 1997 il y avait un certain nombre de
pays qui étaient en voie de
développement qui sont aujourd'hui
devenus émergents qui produisaient peu
de gaz à effet de serre qui se sont mis
en en prodire donc c'est un accord qui
était qui constatait une situation X
mais qui a beaucoup évolué en 20 ans
parce que la dynamique du développement
ne s'arrête pas alors il y a outre le
fait que certains sont sortis d'autres
ont se sont mis à à à produire des gaz à
effet de serre et donc on peut
comprendre le décalage l'amendement dont
nous examinons la ratification
aujourd'hui constitue évidemment et et
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
rassurant un début de réponse à la
question de de l'après Kyoto il prolonge
le protocole pour une de période et
devrait nous conduire si comme on
l'espère tous il est ratifié rapidement
à 2020 l'objectif est la réduction des
émissions des gaz à effet de serre des
parties
concernées d'au moins 18 % par rapport
au niveau 1990 il y a une chose qui est
importante également dans le dans le
l'amendement de DOA c'est que il intègre
un 7è gaz qui est le
trifluorure d'azote alors pour les
spécialistes ça tout le monde comprendra
l'intérêt du d'intégrer le tri
trifluorure d'azote il faut voir que le
tri fluorure d'azote et et la
conséquence d'une convention qui est la
Convention de Vienne et protocole de de
Montréal où vous vous souvenez tous
de l'émotion qui s'était emparé de la
communauté scientifique et de la société
civile sur l'état de la couche d'ozone
il y avait un certain nombre de gaz qui
abîmait la couche d'ozone et la
Convention de Vienne a eu pour objectif
et notamment son Protocole de Montréal
de supprimer ces effets et bien on a
réussi mais on a mis en circulation un
nouveau gaz qui lui est 17000 fois plus
polluant que le dioxyde de carbone donc
il était pertinent de rajouter puisque
même si il aimait moins les effets de
son émission étant 17 mois 17000 fois
supérieur on peut imaginer les dégâts
que ça fait alors il faut régler ce ce
problème là en même temps et je pense
que c'est plutôt une bonne idée
l'amendement de do va entrer en vigueur
le 90e jour suivant la date de réception
par les nations- Unies des instruments
d'acceptation de 190 partis multiplié
par 2/3 ce qui fait 140 si ma mes
calculs sont bons et actuellement il y a
que 21 États qui ont transmis leurs
instruments d'acceptation sur les 144
requis donc on a quand même un petit gap
à accomplir et ça serait bien de le
faire avant que nous nous réunissions
alors l'Union européenne s'est engagée à
le ratifier la France aussi euh
seulement on constate que ça fait 3 ans
que tout ça est en cours et que
aujourd'hui ça serait bien que ça se
passe je pense que puisque nos amis
députés ont déjà ratifié quand nous
allons avoir vootter et je pense qu'il
n'y aura pas de difficulté pour que ça
soit le cas euh ça sera un pas
supplémentaire pour permettre au
gouvernement de déposer les instruments
de ratification entre les mains de
l'Union européenne qui elle-même au nom
de la de la collectivité le fera pour
euh pour le mois de février un accord a
été trouvé euh de justesse ce weekend au
Pérou euh là encore euh le ministre et
la rapporteur en en on en ont dit un mot
euh je partage à la fois le le côté
positif de de l'approche euh c'est mieux
que s'il y avait eu un désaccord même si
l'accord n'est pas extraordinaire c'est
mieux que s'il y avait eu un désaccord
euh le texte qui a été adopté à
l'unanimité fixe la feuille de route
pour l'année 2015 c'est-à-dire que ça
commence à courir puisque euh dans dans
un an ce ce jour dans un an euh il
faudra qu'on soit loin dans la
négociation de de de la COP 21 si on
veut aboutir à quelque chose on voit
bien que les négociations ont à chopé
sur le principe de la différenciation
euh qui est un sujet extrêmement
compliqué et sur le contenu des
contributions à fournir par les États on
a adopté un texte à minima beaucoup de
points restent encore sur la table alors
peut-être un mot sur la question de la
différenciation la la notion de
responsabilité commune mais différencié
est un principe fondamental de la
convention climat signée à Rio en 92
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire la
différenciation c'est que tout le monde
dit qu'on est responsable mais la
responsabilité la différenciation ça
veut dire qu'on peut imaginer par
exemple sans blesser les Sénégalais de
dire que le Sénégal est moins
responsable que la France de la
contribution de l'émission de gaz à
effet de serre puisque le niveau de
développement des deux états n'est pas
le même on comprend bien que tous les
états disent on est solidairement
responsable mais qu'on veut que notre
prise en compte de cette responsabilité
soit différencié c'est un sujet qui est
extrêmement complexe parce que comment
calculer la différenciation d'autant que
cette différenciation comme je le disais
à l'instant est une différenciation
mobile puisque au fur et à mesure qu'on
parle nous faisons des efforts pour
réduire et les États en voie de
développement les états
émergentss progressent dans leur
progressent dans leur consommation et
donc dans leurs émissions de de gaz à
effet de serre euh c'est un des sujets
extrêmement difficiles et on a bien
senti à Lima que le riddissement dont a
parlé madame
Aichi était évident les pays d'Afrique
francophone avec lesquels nous
échangeons beaucoup on les a sentis
assez tendu sur ce sujet et c'est assez
assez légitime de de penser que pour eux
le principe d'équité est un sujet
complexe ronand DC ne manquera pas de
nous expliquer que les Suisses
réfléchissent beaucoup à ce principe
d'équité et et alors c'est pour ça que
je le dis pour toi
euh et quelle sollicitude et et donc
et donc à ce moment-là peut-être
pourrions-nous réfléchir pendant l'année
qui vient à apporter des contributions
sur cette ce concept qui qui n'est
évidemment pas facile et qui sera
indispensable pour trouver une solution
en 2001 le deuxième point d'achopement
ce sont les contribution nationale vous
savez quand en en 2009 à Copenhague
l'échec a été que on a fait arriver les
chefs d'État sur une négociation qui
avait commencé depuis plusieurs semaines
et à laquelle il n'avait pas pris part
là où aujourd'hui on demande pour éviter
cet échec que les États alors l'idée
c'était de le faire avant le Pr à la fin
avant la fin du premier trimestre 2015
après on a dit avant la fin du premier
semestre maintenant on est avant le 1er
novembre autrefois il devait y avoir un
tiers qui vérifierait la la qualité des
productions aujourd'hui ce tiers a été
supprimé c'est seulement madame Figueres
qui donnera son avis madame Figueres
étant la secrétaire exécutive de la
Convention Cadre sur le changement
climatique bref il y a eu des retraits
mais il n'en demeure pas moins que
chaque étape pour participer à la
convention devra avoir apporté la
contribution de son état
à à la à l'effort l'effort à obtenir
c'est c'est ce rapport de synthèse devra
nous être passé pour que au moment où la
convention commence évidemment on puisse
avoir une vue un peu plus précise sur
les points qui a
chopsé un point qui est intéressant dans
la convention qui n'est pas centrale
mais qui est intéressant c'est qu'il y a
une espèce d'annexe de 37 pages qui cons
situe un brouillon pour l'accord de
Paris et dans les conventions
internationales quand on négocie on met
un texte sur la table qui est une
version martyre et dont beaucoup de
dispositions sont qu'on appelle entre
crochets et là il y a beaucoup de
crochets dans le texte de 37 pages parce
que pratiquement on est d'accord sur pas
grand-chose donc le le but des
diplomates qui négocient c'est de faire
en sorte que les crochets sautent un par
un et et progressivement dans l'année
qui vient on va essayer de se rapprocher
pour faire en sorte que il y a le moins
de crochet possible pour laisser aux
chefs d'État euh la responsabilité
politique de faire sauter les derniers é
clivages qui sont les les les derniers
crochets voilà évidemment euh il faut
que les problèmes de la conférence de
l'image je le disais à l'instant ne
soient pas des enfin les problèmes de la
conférence de Paris ne soient pas des
problèmes
inextricables il y a des vraies
difficultés euh et il faut pas les nier
en même temps il y a de vrais avancées
et il faut les saluer parce que ces
vraies avancé devrai nous permettre on
l'espère tous qu'ave avec le dynamisme
de la et la volonté collective partagé
dans notre pays de faire avancer cette
négociation et d'aboutir à un succès à
Paris et bien soit euh euh soit abouti
le temps ne joue pas en notre faveur l'a
dit Monsieur ben kimoun quand on voit
les les événements climatiques qui
secouent le monde à intervalle régulier
qui font la une de nos journaux de nos
journaux de de nos journaux télévisés je
pense qu'il faut pas il faut pas trop
tarder et donc il était urgent euh de
faire que de réparer les erreurs
tactiques qui avaient été commises à à
Copenhague où la convention la confiance
avait vraiment été perturbée aujourd'hui
cette confiance elle a
été on peut dire partiellement mais
réellement rétabli il faut faire en
sorte de la solidifier et je pense que
la France non seulement parce qu'elle
est le pays d'accueil mais parce qu'elle
a historiquement dans la vie de la
France il y a toujours une
responsabilité à la prise de
participation de grandes décisions
collectives je sais si cette affaire de
climat est une grande décision
collective pour l'avenir non seulement
de notre pays mais pour l'avenir de la
planète et donc pour les générations qui
viennent il y en a qui nous regardent
aujourd'hui précisément et donc notre
responsabilité est importante il faut
que nous ayons l'intelligence collective
de de faire avancer ce dossier et et
bien pour vous dire le mot de la fin euh
la commission du développement durable à
l'unanimité a accepté bien évidemment la
ratification du Protocole de DOA et
apporte et apportera évidemment et
invite les les membres de cette
Assemblée à apporter un vote positif à
la demande du gouvernement de
ratification de cette loi je vous
remercie merci monsieur le
rapporteur dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
Madame Michel Demessine pour 7
minutes
bonjour une petite goutte ah tant
pis monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers collègues le
principal mérite du protocole de Kyoto
qui était adopté en 19
97 sur la base du 2è rapport du Groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental sur le
climat et d'être à ce jour l'unique
instrument international juridiquement
contraignant ça a été
rappelé pour réduire ou limiter les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
les pays industrialisés et dans les
économie émergente c'est donc un
instrument juridique d'une grande
qualité il faut le développer
or en arrière-plan de ce type d'accord
multilatéral se profile des négociations
difficiles longue et complexe entre les
États de la planète sous l'œil vigilant
des organisations
nongouvernementales en apparent ces
négociations se se déroulent avec le
seul souci de trouver un juste équilibre
entre les exence du du développement et
celle de la protection de
l'environnement ces conférences des
nations unis sur les changements
climatiques se place à juste titre sous
les auspices du respect des valeurs et
des grands principes commun à toute
l'humanité mais les résultats il faut le
dire sont loin d'être toujours à la
hauteur des ambitions
affichées car en réalité ces grandes
conférences sont
essentiellement le reflet du rapport des
forces internationales du moment qui
lui-même traduit la défense d'intérêts
nationaux ou privés souvent
contradictoirees c'est précisément le
cas pour ce fameux protocole de Kyoto et
l'amendement à cet accord que nous
sommes invités à ratifier ce matin signé
en 1997 et entré en vigueur en 2005
comme il a été rappelé avant moi il
portait sur une première période
d'engagement de 2008 à 2012 mais en 2009
la conférence de Copenhague n'a pas
réussi à adopter ce un dispositif
applicable à l'après 2012 cette
conférence illustra concrètement la
difficulté dont je parlais précemment
précédemment celle de concilier tout à
la fois le développement des peuple et
des sociétés les intérêts économiques et
la préservation de la planète nous
mesurons ainsi la difficulté qu'il y a à
engager une dynamique de préservation de
la planète il aura fallu encore attendre
2 ans avant la conférence de durbane en
2011 pour que les États se mettent
simplement d'accord sur sur une
procédure de de négociation d'un accord
universel contraignant et comprenant le
calendrier suivant 2015 pour l'adoption
du futur accord au sommet de Paris et
2020 pour son entrée en vigueur et c'est
en fonction de ces échéances qu'il est
apparu impératif de couvrir cette
période intermédiaire dont nous parlons
comprise entre la fin 2012 et 2020 tel
est donc l'objet de cet amendement
l'amendement au protocole de Kyoto
l'amendement de DOA que ce projet de loi
invite à ratifier est une solution
d'urgence pour préserver l'actuel
protocole de Kyoto et maintenir ainsi
une action collective internationale de
lutte contre les changements
climatiques mais cette ratification
s'impose aussi au regard de l'agenda
international puisque rappelons qu'à
l'issue de la 20e conférence sur le clim
climat qui vient de se dérouler à Lima
notre pays va devenir officiellement
l'organisateur de la 21e Conférence
mondiale sur le climat appelée la COP 21
dans cette perspective il est évident
que nous devons absolument être à jour
s'agissant de nos engagements
internationaux en matière de lutte
contre le changement climatique à propos
de la conférence de l'IMA je voudrais
relever qu'elle a accouché dans la
douleur c'est-à-dire après 15 jours de
négociation et d'une prolongation de 48
heures d'un accord il faut le dire qui a
profondément déçu les pays du Sud et les
ONG rien de ce qu'il demandait ne figure
clairement dans le dans le compromis
adopté ainsi concernant les
contributions présentées par les pays
aucune avancée n'a pu être n'a pu être
obtenue pour prendre en compte aussi
bien le niveau d'atténuation des gaz à
effet de serre que l'aide à l'adaptation
et au financement rien sur la
transparente et les aides technologiques
ni sur l'équité dans le partage des
responsabilités dans le réchauffement
climatique je crains que les maigres
résultats de ces négociations a pour
effet d'aggraver ce que certains
appellent la fracture
Nord-Sud cette conférence a donné une
nouvelle fois le spectacle d'un
véritable affrontement entre les pays en
développement et les pays
industrialisés ce qui fait qu'aucune des
questions autour desquelles devaient se
construire le futur accord de Paris n'a
malheureusement pu-être pu être précisé
dans ces condition la signature d'un
accord universel en 2015 ambitieux
équitable et gage de son efficacité
légalement contraignant censé prendre le
relais du protocole de Kyoto à partir de
2020 se trouve sur un chemin P pavé
d'embûche monsieur le ministre je mesure
toutes les difficultés qui vous
attendent et qui attendent notre
diplomatie pour réussir cette conférence
de Paris tant attendue pourtant parvenir
à un accord global et différencié est
possible à condition de faire prévaloir
une véritable vision solidaire du
développement humain durable mondial
c'est pourquoi la réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
chaque pays contrairement à ce qui s'est
fait à Lima doit tenir compte des
réalités et des projets de développement
de ces pays pensez ce qu'on appelle
parfois la société post-carbone implique
d'avancer vers un mode productif à
répondre au défis technologiques sociaux
et écologiques de nos sociétés
d'aujourd'hui c'est la fin de
l'obsolescence programmée
l'écoonception l'économie solidaire et
l'efficacité
énergétique l'objectif de limiter le
réchauffement climatique à 2 degrés s'il
est tenu et accepté par tous peut-être
d'une grande porté et avoir des
répercussions très positives sur
l'avenir des millions d'êtres humains
pour concrétiser une vision partagée du
développement humain durable les pays
riches doivent
abonder financièrement les fonds appelés
vert et pertes et dommag créés par l'ONU
il faut aussi qu'il coopère avec les
moins avancé au travers des transferts
de technologie et de brevet associés ces
quelques idées ne sont pas simplement
généreuses elles sont la seule
alternative à la catastrophe qui
guettete les générations futures si nous
sont pas ces idées sont souvent
partagées par les ONG et les opinions
publiques enfin je souhaiterais qu'une
telle conception anime avec force tous
les efforts diplomatiques de la France
pour la réussite de la conférence de
Paris tels sont monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues les réflexions
d'actualité que m'a inspiré ce protocole
de ratification de l'amendement au
protocole de Kyoto et vous l'avez bien
compris le groupe CRC se prononce bien
évidemment
pour son adoption merci de votre
attention merci ma cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Chantal
Jan merci monsieur le président monsieur
le
ministre monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers
collègues c'est vrai que il sera temp de
considérer que cette ratification de
l'amendement au protocole de Kyoto est
une formalité pour certains voir un peu
un temps perdu pour
d'autres depuis
1997 les résultats du protocole de Kyoto
ont été extrêmement limité ça a été
rappelé tout à l'heure les pays
développés à l'époque en réalité avaient
déjà pris des engagements très minimes
puisque l'engagement c'était une
réduction de 5 % de des émissions de de
gaz à effet de serre par rapport à
1990 les États-Unis le plus gros
émetteur déjà à l'époque n'avait pas
souhaité ratifier le protocole de de
Kyoto et pire certains grands pays s'en
sont très rapidement éloignés voire y
ont renoncé comme le Canada le Japon ça
a été évoqué tout à l'heure la
Nouvelle-Zélande et la Chine elle
n'étant pas directement lié à continué à
augmenter ses émissions de gaz à effet
de serre le résultat c'est que sur la
même période les émissions ont augmenté
de 54 % 54 % on serait tenté de
considérer que Kyoto n'a vraiment pas
fait la preuve de son efficacité que la
seconde période qui s'ouvre donc celle
de 2013 à 2000 à 2020 est encore moins
ambitieuse puisqueelle finalement les
pays engagés ne ne touchent que 15 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre parce
que encore une fois les principaux
émetteurs les États-Unis la Chine le
Canada la Russie le chon le Japon pardon
encore une fois ont renoncé ont fuit
leur responsabilité donc on sait qu'en
ratifiant ce protocole ce nouvel
amendement plutôt on on ne sera pas du
tout dans la trajectoire souhaitée pour
limiter les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre on sait qu'on est plutôt sur le
pire des scénarios qui a été évoqué par
le GC dans son dernier rapport c'est une
augmentation de
4,8°g celus d'ici à 2100 or juste pour
mémoire parce que à la limite on
pourrait se dire à Paris que ça pourrait
être agréable juste pour mémoire l'air
glaciaire c'était une température
moyenne de - 5 à - 6°grés par rapport à
aujourd'hui donc on n' pas conscience
aujourd'hui des conséquences de ce
réchauffement de ces changements
climatique et on pourrait se demander
finalement pourquoi est-ce que nous
sommes enfin en tout cas les pays
développés sont aussi cyniques il y a
une très grande tentation aujourd'hui au
renoncement il y a une très grande
tentation à la résignation elle est
alimentée par là aussi mettons un peu
les choses au clair elle est alimentée
par la puissance financière des lobis
pétroliers qui ont été extrêmement
présente extrêmement efficace dans le
cadre des dernières des dernières
négociations elle est alimentée par une
vraie forme de cynisme parce que quand
vous regardez on parle assez peu les
projections sur les pays qui seront les
plus touchés ce sont déjà les pays les
plus
pauvres nous ne serons pas les pays les
plus touchés mais on va l'être
indirectement bien évidemment et
aujourd'hui l'Union européenne qui est
le seul continent réellement
engagé n'arrive pas à convaincre elle
n'arrive pas à convaincre parce que
c'est un indipomatique elle a fait le
choix d'être un indiplomatique elle
n'arrive pas à convaincre parce que elle
parle d'exemplarité de sa responsabilité
alors qu'en réalité ce qu'on a envie
d'entendre aujourd'hui c'est
l'exemplarité du modèle de développement
c'est en quoi ça fonctionne et en quoi
ça marche donc on serait tenté d'être de
ne pas applaudir à la ratification de
cet amendement et pourtant au contraire
en tout cas au groupe udiuc on le
soutient avec ferveur on soutient avec
ferveur parce que Jérôme l'a rappelé
Jérôme Bignon pardon c'est le seul
instrument juridique contraignant
aujourd'hui à à l'échelle internationale
c'est le seul et d'ailleurs je suis
malheureusement un peu convaincu que si
on devait renégocier aujourd'hui Kyoto
on ne parviendrait pas à l'accord qui a
été qui a été trouvé en 1997 on serait
très en de ça de cette accord parce
qu'il y a une vraie forme de recul dans
les négociations dans les négociations
et autant plus les rapports du GC
progressent et plus finalement l'action
elle semble un petit peu régresser à
l'échelle internationale on soutient
parce que c'est l'un des les derniers
instruments
multilatéraux et là aussi on voit avec
force la tentation des accords des
accords régionaux on prend l'exemple du
dernier accord entre la Chine et les
États-Unis on s'est tous senti obligé
d'applaudir parce que c'était la
première fois finalement qu'il prenait
des engagements mais la réalité c'est
que c'est une attaque très frontale
d'accords régionaux vis-à-vis d'une proc
d'un processus multilatéral qu'il faut
coûte que coûte aujourd'hui préserver
parce qu'on ne parviendra pas à régler
cette question sans un processus
multilatéral et enfin on le soutient
parce que la COP 21 de de de Paris ne
pourra être un succès que si on crée une
dynamique positive et ça a été évoqué
effectivement par la plupart des
intervenants il faut ratifier à
l'échelle internationale il faut que cet
amendement passe il faut que toutes les
petites pierres qui permettent de de
pavé la route de Paris soit posée
aujourd'hui avec avec optimisme à Lima
c'est vrai que ça a été un accord à
minima il faut le il faut le reconnaître
et ce que nous avons entendu avec Jérôme
Bignon avec Hervé Moret avec Dantec
était vraiment des des des discours
notamment des pays africains beaucoup
plus fermés qu'auparavant beaucoup plus
dur et beaucoup plus fermé qu'auparavant
donc aujourd'hui il faut vraiment
trouver tout ce qui peut permettre de
créer une dynamique positive c'est pour
ça que nous serions aussi favorable à ce
que le le Sénat puisse engager des
déclarations communes avec d'autres
hautes assemblées à travers le monde
parce que nous sommes les représentants
des territoires et que les territoires
seront les plus touchés par ces
changements climatiques et ce sont
souvent les premiers acteurs de ces
contre ces changements climatiques et
parce que aujourd'hui on a vraiment en
tout cas en politique on s'est très très
bien transformer toutes les petites
pierres en œuvre d'art alors cette
qualité cette capacité utilisons-la
abusons de cette capacité pour vraiment
engager la voie de de Paris merci merci
madame la
Présidente la parole est à Monsieur
alain
GOURNAC
monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues cette convention devait être
examinée en procédure simplifié
toutefois je pense que cette séance en
dépit de la qualité des interventions et
des orateurs nous laissera un peu sur
notre fin parce que le sujet est
important trop important très
important pour tenir en une heure
néanmoins cela nous permettra de poser
quelques éléments de réflexion en vue de
la préparation de la 21e conférence des
partis de la convention cadre des
Nations Unies sur le changement
climatique en 2015 la COP
21 je sais que notre commission
travaillera sur ce sujet et je tiens à
remercier son président à cet instant
mes chers collègues je voudrais citer
une phrase qui tragiquement et plus que
jamais est d'actualité notre maison
brûle et nous regardons
ailleurs il y a 14 ans 14 ans déjà lors
du Sommet de la Terre le 2 septembre
2002 à Johannesbourg Jacques Chirac
devant tous les représentants de la
scène diplomatique mondiale tirait la
sonette d'alarme sur les conséquences
des bouleversements climatiques
oui la planète brûle du fait du
réchauffement climatique dont une part
est largement du au gaz à effet de
serre c'est l'objet de notre vote
aujourd'hui permettre la poursuite du
protocole de Kyoto pour la période
2013-2020 l'urgence de la situation et
l'importance de la réussite de la COP 21
ne sont plus à
démontrer les conséquences géopolitiques
et humaines des changements climatiques
sont planétaires dès lors le spessimisme
et l'attentisme sont des postures
intolérables comme l'a également dit
Jacques Chirac en 2002 nous ne pourrons
pas dire que nous ne savions pas nen
déplaise à Monsieur Claude Allègre les
analyses et les rapports du GC Le Groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat ne peuvent être
remis en
cause je tiens à remercier très
sincèrement ma collègue Leya Achi pour
ce rapport j'aime bien travailler avec
elle je dois pouvoir le dire en public
non pardon peut-être qu'il faut pas et
bien sûr notre collègue Jérome brigon
pour son rapport au nom de la commission
du développement durable sauf mon cher
collègue la tour de Babel c'est pas là
ici qu'il faut nous l'amener ça pas été
une grande réussite et moi je souhaite
que nous allions vers la réussite dans
ce combat là la tour de Babel on
l'utilise quand même souvent dans une
approche de non réussite voilà je
voulais te le dire mais en toute
amitié sur ce sujet de peut y avoir
quand au fond ni clivage politique ni
polémique partisane il est de notre
responsabilité non seulement de trouver
des solutions des mécanismes permettant
d'atteindre les objectifs fixés à ce
jour mais également mais également de
nous préparer au futurs critères de
réduction d'émissions des gaz et effets
de serre je ne reviendrai pas sur
l'historique du protocole depuis
1997 je voudrais toutefois attirer votre
attention sur le décalage entre les
négociations les ratifications et Infiné
les applications réelles de ces accords
par les États et surtout sur le
revirement de la part des pays
signataires au début du protocole en
réalité les enjeux d'aujourd'hui tienent
aux évolutions de certains de ces pays
beaucoup d'entre eux ont changé de
statut ils sont plus au stade de pays en
voie de développement leur
croissance et leur production
industrielle sont telles qu'on peut les
qualifier
d'énergivor pour ma part je pense
d'ailleurs qu'ils ne vont plus vraiment
être classés dans les pays émergents
ainsi ces pays ont annoncé qu'il ne
renont pas leur engagement estimant que
cela pélaniserait leurs économies je
pense à la Russie et aux déclarations de
Dimitri mvedef d'octobre
2012 d'autres pays se sont carrément
retirés des négociations du protocole
comme le Canada si on pense au grand
projet du Grand Nord qui est mise en
place actuellement nous pouvons avoir
quelques inquiétudes de modestes
inquiétudes en outre les États-Unis et
la Chine ont signé le 12 novembre
dernier un accord que tous les
observateurs qualifient d'historique ça
ça a été un
important c'est heureux que les les deux
premières puissances économiques de la
planète les plus polluantes s'engage
dans la réduction des du gaz à effet de
serre si cet accord fixe des objectifs
chiffrés d'ici 2030 il ne contient
cependant aucun instrument juridique
contraignant il permet en revanche que
se renforce l'axe diplomatique
sininoaméricain conformément à la
volonté américaine de se concentrer sur
l'Asie alors dans la perspective de la
COP 21 qui se tiendra à Paris l'année
prochaine nous devons nous interroger
sur cet accord que cela signifie-t-il
pour l'avenir des négociations
internationales sur la réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre la
Chine avait ratifié le protocole puis
s'en est retiré en 2007 quand aux
États-Unis n'ont jamais ratifié cet
accord et le Canada en décembre 2011 a
annoncé qu'il souhaitait se désengager
c'est choses faites aujourd'hui les pays
qui le respectent sont aujourd'hui
responsables de moins de 26 % 26 % des
émissions de gaz à effet ser dans le
monde contre 56 % au moment de la
signature en
1997 cuit de l'Inde et du Brésil pays
émetteurs pays signataire mais pays
exemptés de contraintes ces deux pays en
plein développement ont mis en place des
politiques nationales de limitation des
émissions mais restent réticent face à
un engagement international contraignant
susceptible de menacer leur croissance
économique aujourd'hui il est à craindre
que les pays les plus émetteurs préfèent
entamer des négociations avec des États
non signateurs de protocole en refusant
tout mécanisme qui serait une contrainte
alors bien sûr le groupe UMP votera ce
texte c'est pas news he tout le monde
s'en
doutait il le votera en demandant au
chefs de l'état de s'engager totalement
monsieur le ministre ce combat il faut
en effet qu'il réussisse à convaincre
ses homologues pour que les efforts
engagés depuis 2005 et la COP 21 ne
débouche pas sur un un échec et puis
aussi la diplomatie dans ce domaine doit
être le fer de lance de notre
détermination il en va de la
préservation de notre planète mes chers
collègues je vous remercie merci mon
cher collègue la parole est à Monsieur
ronand
DECT
voilà
exact monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur le Président
chers collègu il y a quel jours donc la
conférence de l'IMA se concluait
difficilement dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche sur un appel de l'IMA pour
l'action sur le climat qui a son point
17 encourage je cite toutes les parties
au Protocole de Kyoto de ratifier et
mettre en œuvre l'amendement de DOA à ce
protocole de Kyoto notre débat
aujourd'hui est donc une première
réponse concrète et nécessaire de la
France pour créer une dynamique en vue
de la COP 21 souignons quand même même
que à ce stade assez peu de pays ont
pour l'instant ratifié cet amendement de
DOA ça montre la la faiblesse des
dynamiques aujourd'hui sur la
négociation sur le climat beaucoup
d'attentisme et je pense que la la
phrase clé de ces négociations depuis
maintenant une décennie c'est bien je
bouge si tu bouges et réciproquement
néanmoins cet amendement de DOA est un
amendement important c'est un des socles
de l'accord de Durban qui lui a permis
d'enclencher un nouveau cycle de nég
iciation après l'échec de kopenhag même
si un texte a été ratifié à Cancun
l'année suivante et c'est ce nouveau
cycle de négociation durbane qui doit
évidemment déboucher à Paris dans 12
mois cet accord de durbane il faut le
rappeler a été obtenu par la
mobilisation du groupe Afrique un peu à
la surprise des grands émergents et il
prévoit pour la première fois des
engagements de tous les pays et pas
seulement des anciens pays développés
concernés par l'accord de Kyoto annexe 1
et 2 et c'est éta ce pas qui était
absolument essentiel pour créer un
nouveau C parce que comme ça a été dit
évidemment les pays qui sont aujourd'hui
dans le protocole de Kyoto c'est une
part minime des émissions mondiales et
donc sans les engagements des grands
émergents et des États-Unis on ne peut
pas rentrer sur une trajectoire de degré
donc maintenant si le cadre est fixé par
cet accord de d'urbane complété donc
aujourd'hui de l'appel de liimma la
précision pour ne pas dire la beauté du
tableau final reste totalement à
apprécier plusieurs s'affronte il y a
les impressionnistes qui souhaitent
quand même que les traits restent
légèrement flous il y a l'inverse des
pointillistes et à la fin malgré tout on
peut craindre surtout un dessin un
dessin surréaliste sur le principe du
CAD du cadravre exqui non on espère donc
que ça ne sera pas le qualificatif final
de l'accord de Paris les difficiles
négociations de la nuit à Lima que nous
avons subi à quelquesuns je vais pas
vous raconter mes nu àim mais il se
trouvait que moi j'intervenais après les
négociateurs après les négociateurs donc
j'avais besoin qu'il finisse pour
pouvoir parler et j'ai donc dû parler
vers 3h du matin dimanche avec l'avion
le lendemain matin mais donc les
difficiles négociations de de liima ont
relevé deux points clés de difficulté
pour l'accord de Paris il y a eu deux
blocages par les pays en développement à
travers l'intervention du Soudan pour le
groupe Afrique très ferme comme a dit
Chantal avec des des Africains
aujourd'hui assez dur dans leur discours
et par les pays émergents à travers là
aussi un discours très ferme de la
Malaisie deux blocages et pas un je
crois que ça c'est important de le
souligner enfin on parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on peut souvent
lire nous n'ons pas eu un affrontement
classique nord- sudud annexe 2 contre
G77 il faut donc répondre à deux
questions tout d'abord bien sûr la
question du développement c'est
l'Afrique je l'ai dit qui a débloqué la
négociation sur le climat àurban mais
elle n'est pas aujourd'hui payée en
retour l'engagement de Copenhague le
seul engagement de copenhag les 100
milliards par an pour le fond vert sont
encore très loin d'être réunis on s'est
réjoui des premers milliards dont 1
milliard de la France qui était un
engagement fort du président Hollande au
sommet de Banky Moon mais c'est peu
c'est 10 milliards sur 4 ans là il
faudrait 100 milliards par an à partir
de 2020 c'estàd il faut trouver 25 fois
plus et en donner des pistes précise à
Paris l'année prochaine alors comment il
y a à augmenter les financements directs
et je sais que les négociations sur le
climat sont souvent le concours de la
phrase la plus définitive et Jacques
Chirag n'est pas le plus mauvais à ce
jeu-là
mais ça ne va pas suffire y compris dans
notre responsabilité ici au Parlement il
faudra voter demain l'augmentation des
aides directes au pays du Sud quelle que
soit notre situation budgétaire sinon il
n'y aura pas d'accord sur le climat et
on verra là si les grandes phrases sont
suivies de de fait il y aura à trouver
de nouveaux types de financement lei en
a parlé notamment sur les transactions
financières il faudra trouver ces
nouveaux mécanismes c'est compliqué il y
a le mécanisme du développement propre
le fait d'engager au aujourd'hui par
cette ratification la deuxème période du
protocole de Kyoto il ne faut pas
oublier que dans le protocole de Kyoto
il y a une part d'engagement de
solidarité vers le sud qui s'appelle le
mécanisme de développement propre adossé
j'ai pas le temps évidemment dans ce
cour de temps adossé au système européen
de mise aux enchères des tonnes de CO2
si nous réussissons à retrouver
l'ambition en Europe nous augmenterons
le prix de la tonne CO2 nous
augmenterons donc les financements du
mécanisme de développement propre c'est
un des éléments qui permet de trouver
les les 100 milliards mais je n'ai pas
le temps d'y revenir la deuxième demande
la deuxième demande c'est celle des pays
émergents elle est différente de celle
des pays encore véritablement en
développement ce que veulent les pays
émergents aujourd'hui il l'ont redit
très fortement à l'IMA en bloquant la
négociation c'est ce respect qui est
dans le principe du de Kyoto de la
responsabilité commune mais différencié
comment fait-on évoluer les économies
mondiales comment fait-on converger les
économies entre anciens pays développé
et pays émergents dans ce cadre
contraint de la lutte contre le
changement climatique c'est la question
à laquelle il faut faut répondre et
comme disait jérame Bignot Jérome Bignot
tout à l'heure certains pays travaillent
la question de l'équité est au cœur de
l'accord de de Paris il faut trouver des
pays médiateur la Suisse par exemple
travaille sur ces modélisation d'une
idée de l'équité si on ne répond pas à à
la question de l'équité économique alors
on ne pourra pas trouver non plus
d'accord à Paris et dernière idée
importante et tu l'as dit c'est
qu'effectivement entre les engagements
connus aujourd'hui qui nous mène plutôt
sur une trajectoire 3 degrés et les 2
degrés que nous impose la communauté
scientifique pour rester dans une zone
tolérable pour l'évolution de nos
sociétés mais il faudra déjà s'adapter à
à 2 degrés alors il faut des dynamiques
fortes des acteurs non étatiques et
liima a été l'occasion à travers
notamment ce ce moment ce Lima Climate
Action Summit coprésidé par ban kimoun
le ministre français Laurent Fabius et
le ministre péruvien de remettre en
scène c'était aussi le cas au sommet de
banquimon en septembre l'action des
acteurs non étatiques les entreprises
les Sit citoyens dans leur comportement
à travers leurs ONG et puis les
collectivités territoriales que je
représente dans ces négociations
internationales c'est cette dynamique
des acteurs non étatiques qui doit être
aussi très présente à Paris qui
permettra de crédibiliser une
trajectoire de degrés et très
probablement nous le savons déjà les
engagements des états n n'y suffiront
pas donc aujourd'hui nous avons un
brouillon un draft texte en langage
onusien je dirais une esquise pour
garder euh la même approche que tout à
l'heure et les quatre piliers
pour un accord à Paris on les connaît
donc ambition européenne tout d'abord et
il fallait donc aujourd'hui ratifier
l'amendement de DOA réponse forte
financièrement crédiible sur les enjeux
du développement définition partagée
d'un principe d'équité qui rapproche
ancien pays développés et pays émergent
sur une vision commune d'une régulation
économique mondiale et soutien aux
initiatives des acteurs non étatiques
voilà donc les quatre piliers d'un
accord ambitieux à Paris je vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue
je vais mettre au
voix madame Nicole brick vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président pour
une explication de vote le groupe
socialiste évidemment ratifiera cet
amendement et ça me
permet de motiver cette explication bien
sûr la ratification de l'amendement au
protocole de Kyoto et je pense une une
pierre puisqu'il en a été question très
important
entre liima et Paris la conférence que
la
France organise et on sait depuis
Copenhague qu'il est très important que
la présidence de la conférence soit non
seulement active mais déterminé à
aboutir et nous avons encore en mémoire
cet échec de la présidence danoise il
faut le dire même si il y a des
diplomates qui écoutent mais c'était
quand même le cas alors évidemment
toutes ces grandes conférences
internationales le verre n'est jamais à
moitié plein ou à moitié vide c'est
quelquefois confus les orateurs de la
matinée l'ont rappelé mais 18 ans
bientôt après
le l'engagement
pris par le Protocole de
Kyoto les choses ont quand même beaucoup
bougé dans la mesure
où on l'oublie peut-être en France mais
euh les
échanges sud- sudud constituent plus du
quart des échange de la planète donc ce
qui a changé fondamentalement c'est
l'arrivée des grands émergents qui notre
collègue ourournac a raison qui sont
quand même largement immergés pour
certains et je crois que le bilatéral
peut aider le multilatéral madame joanau
j'ai plutôt tendance à dire que ce qui a
été fait à Pékin entre le président
Obama et le président chichiping est
positif pour la suite de la négociation
de de Paris mais c'est vrai vous avez
raison chers collègu il faudra aussi
faire attention à à l'Inde et au Brésil
moi j'ai vécu une grande conférence
internationale c'était Ario Janero en
2012 j'étais brièvement ministre de
l'écologie euh et j'ai vécu ce qui se
passe dans ces grandes conférences
internationales euh on voit bien qu'il y
a des jeux de couloirs importants et que
certains pays émergents sont capable
d'entraîner ou pas dans un refus ou dans
un accord les pays africains donc il
faut bien avoir ça en tête euh il y a
des aspects positifs pour le succès de
Paris mais il y a aussi des aspects qui
n'ont peut-être pas encore été
suffisamment euh explorés et puis je
voudrais rappeler quand même que dans
ces grandes négociations internationale
comme personne n'en a parlé euh la
France se situe en Europe et l'Union
européenne c'est elle qui porte euh la
négociation et euh nous sommes bien sûr
très actifs au travers de la présidence
mais aussi euh en tant que membre de
cette union européenne qui a pris des
engagements tant sur le CL ma que sur
les énergies renouvelables et c'est vrai
que euh cette signature cette
ratification ce matin comme tous les
engagements européens et mondiaux nous
euh nous font regarder le modèle de
développement et c'est sûr que si
nous-mêmes nous n'évoluons pas fortement
dans notre de modèle de développement en
Europe et bien nous aurons des
difficultés à faire en sorte que des
pays qui ne sont pas encore émergents
qui pourrai l'être je pense notamment
aux pays africains auront du mal à
s'intégrer dans le mouvement mondial
alors je voudrais terminer par justement
par rapport à à cela moi
j'attends que le plan
junkerer au niveau de l'Union européenne
prennent complètement en compte ses
engagements parce que je vois bien que
le charbon bah il est non seulement de
retour dans certains pays mais il est
c'est une ressource fossile qui se
développe beaucoup donc ça pose quand
même une vraie question à nous tous en
tant qu'Européen et en même temps je
suis
persuadée que tant qu'on aura pas
donneré un prix au
carbone on aura un sérieux problème et
euh nous avons été les premiers nous
Européens à créer un marché du carbone
qui s'est
effondré mauvaise allocation de quota
allocation nationale à partir de là et
la crise par là-dessus économique
européenne donc le prix est effondré et
je pense que c'est pas forcément une
utopie il faut voir mondial et ce n'est
qu'à partir du moment où on aura été
capable d'engager ces travaux pour avoir
un prix du carbone mondial que vraiment
on aura la solution au problème du
climat et c'est pas une utopie parce que
moi je regrette tout à l'heure on
parlait de
convention avec Andor on parlait
aussi on peut parler de convention
fiscal mais vous savez
quand les pays du G20 se sont réunis en
2009 au plus fort de la crise économique
et qu'ils ont décidé euh dans leurs
conclusion de faire la chasse aux
paradis fiscaux de faire euh en sorte
que euh la fiscalité reviennent aux
États et bien finalement quand on
regarde ça a pas mal avancé donc je
crois que pour le prix du carbone à la
bonne échelle ça peut avancer et moi j'y
crois MERCI ma cher
collègue je vais mettre au voix
l'article unique constituant l'ensemble
du projet de loi adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée autorisant la
ratification de l'amendement au
protocole de Kyoto du 11 décembre
1997 qui est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient le projet de loi est adopté
définitivement voilà pour les débats des
sénateurs sur cet amendement protocole
de Kyoto qui prévoit donc de prolonger
les engagements des parties qui avaient
participé à ce protocole conclu en
1997 seul accord juridiquement
contraignant existant aujourd'hui au
niveau international en matière de
réduction des émissions des gaz à effet
de serre cela en attendant le grand
sommet de Paris qui se tiendra à la fin
de l'année grand sommet sur le climat
qui se rassemblera plus de 190 pays qui
ont pour objectif de parvenir à un
nouvel accord contraignant en matière de
réduction des gaz à effet de serre
rappelons que c'est une véritable
nécessité et que dernièrement François
Hollande le président de la République a
appelé à un accord historique dans ce
domaine vous pouvez toujours voir et
revoir toutes les séances sur notre site
publicsena.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
pour la commission mixte paritaire sur
la simplification de l'avis des
entreprises l'acte 1 du choc de
simplification de François Hollande très
bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires enin beumont dans le nord
de la France est la première ville à
avoir voté Front national dès le premier
tour des municipales de mars 2014
pendant 12 ans le réalisateur a suivi la
spectaculaire percée du FN jusqu'à la
victoire de Steve briwais candidat
et méthodique sur une terre de gauche
désabusée moi je suis pour le Front
national croyz qu'on aide les les sans
abri non par contre les r et compagnie
oui on les aide
basiné samedi à 22h sur Public
Sénat
entre terre et mer le Bassin d'Arcachon
écrin naturel aux portes de l'océan
atlantique mais alimenté en eau douce
par un fleuve la laire c'est une petite
mer intérieur qui connaît un essort
depuis la seconde moitié du 19e siècle
et la création de la ligne ferroviaire
bordeau Arcachon la dune du Pilar le bon
d'Arguin les Pors austréc la pointe du
Cap Ferré le delta de la lire et ses
oiseaux autant d'atout autant d'espace à
protéger le Bassin d'Arcachon un
équilibre à trouver entre tourisme
économie austrécole et
environnement
bonjour Olivier
bonjour Olivier Laban austréculteur
depuis 25 ans veille jalousement sur son
paradis et outil de
travail un endroit comme celi-là en 25
ans il ne peut qu'évoluer on essaie de
faire en sorte qu'il évolue dans le bon
sens qui est pas toujours
évident déjà il y a un peu moins de
d'ostriculteur donc un peu moins de de
parcelles qui sont qui sont occupé donc
du coup entretenu et on sait le rôle
important qu'on les les ostriculteurs
sur sur l'entretien du du milieu des
parcs à vitre quoi donc c'estàdire que
notre travail au quotidien qui consiste
à en gros à à jardiner les les fonds du
du bassinarcachon hein on est les on est
les paysans de la mer quoi hein euh
permet justement d'avoir un entretien
régulier au même titre que les
agriculteurs sur euh dans les champs
quoi si si il avit plus de d'agriculteur
en France on aurait des friches un peu
partout donc sur le Bassin d'Arcachon
c'est la même
chose la conchiliculture comme gage de
préservation du milieu naturel depuis
des années et encore aujourd'hui les
Aust réiculteurs sont les gardiens du
temple les gardesfous des fonds marins
de l'eau du bassin les meilleurs
sentinelles du milieu en fait ce sont
les huîres c'est elles qui au quotidien
capte tout ce qui se passe dans l'eau et
au travers des des résultats
d'analyse parce qu'on le sait l'hure est
un produit énormément contrôlé quand il
y a un dysfonctionnement de milieu ça se
retrouve au travers de de l'huîre et ce
qu'on pourrait appeler l'œil du
mollusque
révèle les les différents
dysfonctionnements qui peut y avoir dans
le milieu donc voilà entre l'huîre qui
surveille et l'ostriculteur qui est au
zagué c'est difficile
de de de passer à
travers 315 entreprises produisent
environ 9000 tonnes d'huître chaque
année l'austréiculture fait vivre 1500
personnes le Bassin d'Arcachon est une
gigantesque pouponnière à H c'est le
plus grand centre naisseur austrécole
européen le jeu c'est arrivé à à les
faire pousser donc là on voit toute la
toute la pousse qu'elle a pu faire on
voit la différence là celle-là elle est
un peu étouffée elle a pas encore poussé
on voit la différence de développement
qui peut y avoir on voit toute la
dentelle tout ça c'est de la pousse donc
là là on est sur une huîre qui démarre
bien bien ronde bien
coffrée qui nous permettra de faire une
belle huîre dans il reste encore 2 ans
et demi d'élevage donc on a encore le
temps de de se
parler selon les années 60 à 90 % de ces
naissins de ces bébé hues disparaissent
avant d'atteindre leur taille adulte
concrètement dès que l'eau va se
réchauffer ici un mois ben on va
considérer que sur ce tas là il y a
environ tout ça qui va disparaître tout
ça va mourir et il va nous rester que
ça une déperdition considérable le
responsable un airp virus très agressif
qui sévit depuis 2008 conséquence une
vigilance accrue des contrôles renforcés
la qualité de l'eau est devenue une
obsession pour toute une économie
associée à l'identité même du
bassin c'est une filière professionnelle
qui mobilise depuis longtemps
l'attention des pouvoirs public derrière
les austriiculteurs les maires des 10
communes concernées ici la conscience
écologique est présente depuis des
années au départ en réalité c'est une
volonté de l'État puisque dans les
années 70 l'État a créé la Miaka mission
d'aménagement de la côte d'akitain qui a
élaboré un schéma et qui a fondé l'idée
de développement de ce territoire qui
était un peu en désérance sur
l'aménagement et les zones préservées et
donc c'est cette stratégie là qui a été
mise en place au départ par l'État euh
qui aujourd'hui irigue la culture
politique et et surtout la population
qui est extrêmement attachée à la
qualité de ce milieu et on a
effectivement la chance d'avoir un
milieu qui est assez exceptionnel et où
on a réussi à la fois à faire du
développement euh et en même temps euh à
avoir une protection qui effectivement
si on la compare au sud-est n'a rien à
voir protéger la qualité des EAU premier
défi écologique initié dès la fin des
années
60 tout ceci a été anticipé puisque ça
fait déjà 20 ans que le Bassin
d'Arcachon a un réseau d'assainissement
euh qui couvre 99,9 % des résidences il
n'y a plus aucun rejet lié à
l'assaainissement dans le bassin
d'Arcachon les 10 communes du bassin
compte aujourd'hui 110000 habitants sur
les 20 dernières années la population a
augmenté de 30 %. l'urbanisation
galopante et la pression démographique
menace constamment l'équilibre du bassin
les maîtriser est un combat
quotidien
alors le site est fragile parce que
comme tout site il est soumis à la à
l'anthropisation c'estàdire à l'activité
de l'homme il y a beaucoup de il y a
beaucoup de de pression sur ce sur ce
sur ce plan d'eau des des pressions qui
évidemment ont un impact sur le milieu
et c'est ça qu'il faut surveiller
équilibrer alors je je vais parler plus
plus concrètement bien sûr c'est donc un
plan d'eau ouvert au Tourist aux
activités de plaisance à toutes les
activités touristiques et le tourisme
est fondamental pour ce plan d'eau et la
vie des hommes mais il faut respecter un
certain nombre
d'équilibre l'été des dizaines de
milliers de vacanciers viennent profiter
des charmes de ce site naturel unique
entre juin et août la population est
multiplié par 3 sur le bassin c'est un
embouteillage de bateau ressence
13000 des bateaux de plaisance qui
perturbent le milieu naturel l'été c'est
le moment où les larves dure cherche un
support pour se fixer et grandir une
étape cruciale troublée par le va et
vient des
moteurs mais une autre menace pèse sur
les fonds marins les peintures
antisalissur dont sont verniis les
coques des bateaux extrêmement nocive
pour les microalgues et les
coquillages tous ti la
d'alarme la Pollion c'est un seuil
c'est-à-dire c'est quand la nature ne
peut plus absorber la nature elle
absorbe des choses mais quand elle peut
plus absorber on voit le dégât et quand
on voit le dégât c'est qu'elle c'est
déjà bien c'est comme un iceberg qui a
déjà beaucoup beaucoup de de de dégâts
fait donc il faut éviter d'arriver à ce
à ce point de
rupture c'est beaucoup moins connu et
moins médiatisé le Bassin d'Arcachon est
une escale essentielle pour des millions
d'oiseaux en effet il est situé au cœur
de l'un des huit couloirs de migrations
les plus importants de la
planète il y a 40 ans des associations
de naturalistes créent une réserve
ornitologique au fond du bassin un
espace protégé riche de ses roselières
mar prairies et
forêts cet endroit le delta de la l'ire
est très important dans la migration des
oiseaux oui oui oui absolument alors
parce que on est sur c'est en fait
l'unité bassin d'Arcachon qui est sur
ces zones de migration et et toute
l'année on a des migrateurs ici qui
viennent qui partent vers le nord ou qui
descendent vers le sud et on est
forcément on est à un endroit absolument
stratégique pour eux parce que comme
tout oiseau en migration il a besoin de
nourriture et ici il trouve les
conditions de repos et de nourriture
combien d'espèces transitent par ici
alors sur cet petit espace là puisque
nous on est gestionnaire de ce petit
espace là qui est 110 hactares il y a
exactement 318 espèces
observables qui sont ici alors
évidemment vous les voyez pas en une
seule fois mais 318 c'est tout au long
de l'année et c'est quand même une
biodiversité assez assez importante sur
un tout petit
espace on est donc zone de protection
spéciale au titre de la des directives
européennes habitat Natura 2000 et on a
on est aussi zone d'importance
internationale pour les oiseaux d'eau au
trre d'un certain nombre d'espèces
ou extrêmement menacé par exemple
con la gorge bleue ou d'autres comme la
spatule
encore la cigone bien plus connu voilà
effectivement on joue un rôle très
important pour un certain nombre
d'espè une oasis un havre de paix
aménager entre le Grenland et l'Afrique
pour Stern COG FX et autres
volatiles vous avez vu qu'on est donc
sur le Bassin d'Arcachon un espace
malgré tout même si on dit que c'est un
espace naturel en gros c'est aussi un
espace très urbanisé où l'homme a
toujours été présent et donc ces
espaces sauvages protégés entre deux
urbanisations ou au fond du bassin au
cœur de de zones comme un delta ici sont
extrêmement importante pour pour la
faune la flore et évidemment pour les
oiseaux et les oiseaux d'eau puisque on
accueille ici essentiellement des
oiseaux d'eau donc effectivement il faut
garder ces poumons poumons vert ces
espaces là parce que le vrai prédateur
de la nature c'est en fait
l'urbanisation c'est la fin de cette
émission vous pouvez la retrouver comme
d'habitude sur notre site internet
public
sena.fr je vous laisse avec cette
citation d'Antoine sa nouséritons pas de
de nos parents nous l'empruntons à nos
enfants à très bientôt
ciao si 90 % des jouets vendus en France
sont fabriqués en Chine le Jura n'a pas
dit son dernier mot en bois ou le plus
souvent plastique portant parfois la
griffe de grands plasticien la filière
jouée est en train de se reconstruire
les partenariats avec les artistes au
départ c'est un Paris risqué puis on
s'aperçoit en fait que ça marche
vraiment made in France aujourd'hui à
16h sur publ
Sat
Berlusconi ne laisse personne
indifférent personne on est d'accord
avec lui ou on le
déteste il n'a pas d'idéo il a juste des
intérêts une fois il m'a dit P 1968 vous
pensz à faire la révolution moi je
faisais déjà de l'argent et vous vous
demandiez comment faire la
révolutioné nous avons une classe
politique d'imbécile Berluscon n c pas
très brillant mais c'est le moins pire
de
tous
quel chapitre magnifique Berlusconi et
les
femmes c'est le menteur le plus sincère
qui existe il arrive à raconter
n'importe quoi et à se convaincre que
c'est
vrai c'est ce qu'on appelle une tyranie
moderne voilà ce qu'a été le
berlusconisme
ici en Italie tout ce qui arrive c'est
de la faute de
Berlusconi e mia mamma mi ha detto e
allora voleva dire che er il numero un
l'unico
fils né d'une famille de la petite
bourgeoisie
milanaise son père luig est employé de
banque sa mère femme au
foyer à 19 ans il s'inscrit en fac de
droit il rencontre alors celui qui
deviendra l'un de ses meilleurs amis un
homme qui accompagnera syvio Berlusconi
durant toute sa carrière
50 ans d'une fidélité
absolue
berlus m'est apparu immédiatement comme
quelqu'un d'extraordinaire hors du
commun à la fac il faisait des fiches de
résumé pour chaque
matière puis lesendait par exemple tout
ce qu'il faut savoir pour réussir
l'examen de philosophie du
droit ces fiches à moi il me les
offra
l'étudiant Berlusconi n'a qu'une
obsession faire de l'argent il enchaîne
les petits boulots vendeur d'aspirateurs
chanteur sur des bateaux de croisière il
touche à
tout séducteur bosseur blagueur en 1962
un an après avoir obtenu sa licence en
droit il décroche un empr bancaire il
fond prièreéé
chantiers de mil c'est le début d'une
foudroyante réussite dans l'immobilier
pour ses proches qui entretiennent la
légende Berlusconi est avant tout un
visionnaire une fois il m'a emmené sur
un terrain de foot qui était recouvert
de brume on y voyait
rien et il m'a dit tu vois cet endroit
un jour j'y construirai une ville mais
une ville où il y aura tout de la
maternité au cimetière avec des banques
des pharmacies des magasins absolument
tout moi je me suis dit ce mec est fou
on ne voit rien ici et bien cette ville
a vu le jour et elle s'appelle Milano
doué Berlusconi a réussi un Paris de
dingue Milan doué est situé à 20 km de
Milan 6000 personnes y vivent un rêve à
l'américaine mais aussi le jackpot pour
l'entrepreneur qui semble bénéficier de
solides appuis
politiques il réussit ainsi à obtenir la
déviation des avions qui atterrissent à
l'aéroport voisin le prix du mètre carré
double du jour au
lendemain mais ce succès incontestable
suscite des interrogations qui a avancé
les 2 milliards nécessaires à la
construction de cette ville parfaite
Berlusconi a toujours refusé de
s'expliquer à Milan auoué il va même
créer une télévision locale et pour ça
il fait appel à un jeune intello fou de
cinéma Carlo fretchero
er innamorato d
tvprio j'ai travaillé à ces côté sur les
programmes des nuits
entières il aime le
spectacle et donc il aimait beaucoup ce
travail il travait 15 16 20 par
jour avec lui il n'y avait pas d'horaire
c'est une de ces caractéristiques il a
besoin de peu de sommeil il le dit
lui-même j'ai vécu de vies parce qu'au
lieu de dormir je travaille il dort 4
heur par jour pas
plus berlcon se prend de passion pour sa
minuscule cha locale elle lui servira de
laboratoire
télévisuel
fais
it pr teste une idée totalement nouvelle
pour l'époque en Italie il trouve
touteses émissions de F sex à peine vê
c'est une révolution face à la télé
d'État la RA grise triste et
puritaine il est aussi le premier des
Mar à
Laé un jour il m'a dit au 4e étage de
cet
immeuble il y a qure personnes qui font
des
sondages toutes les 30 minutes ils
appellent 100 personnes pour savoir
quelle audience font tes
programmes d'un coup je me rends compte
qu'il y a quelque chose de nouveau qui
se joue
l'audience c'est le public qui détermine
les choix
télévisés
le public doit voir ces programmes il
doit les consommer parce qu'en les
consommant il consomme aussi de la
publicité maintenant ça semble normal
mais à l'époque c'était une révolution
totale
totale avec ses filles en petite culotte
Berlusconi a trouvé la recette du succès
télé en 1980 à 44 ans il crée la
première chaîne nationale privée Canal
chinue
elle deviendra le navire amiral de
l'Empire
berlousconien l'entrepreneur immobilier
se transforme en empereur des médias
télévision radio journaux maison
d'édition publicité cinéma rien ne lui
échappe il devient l'homme le plus riche
d'Italie donc il fait la maison pour la
famille idéale italienne la télé pour
les
Italiens l'équipe de foot le Milan AC
pour les
Italiens et après tous ces succès la
politique était
inévitable la politique Berlusconi y
pense il va profiter du plus
retentissant scandale
politico-judiciaire de l'Italie
contemporaine pour saisir sa chance nous
sommes au tout début des années
c'est un moment
historique les anciens par Politi
italien sont sous le des
magistrats laasseque traditionnelle
Lamin par les scandales de corruption et
notamment à par les enquêtes par le
juge
commire min
sp dans son cabinet ils en ressortent
mis en
examen l' de choc remonte au plus haut
sommet de l'État l'ex président du
Conseil Grand Am de
Berlusconi lui aussi rattrapé par le
scandale l'Italie est au bord de la
Révolution
di piietro devient le héros de tout un
pays qui rêve d'une nouvelle génération
de politiciens la Chambre des députés
est
laminé en seulement 2 mois 270
parlementaires sont mis en examen
l'opération m propre a provoqué
l'effondrement de tout le système
politique et les grands partis qui
avaient gouverné l'Italie presque
quasiment depuis la depuis la la fin de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale notamment la
démocratie chrétienne et dans une
certaine mesure le Parti socialiste ont
été
décimés par les enquêtes et par les
scandales de
corruption à l'époque vctorios Garbi est
un polémiste outrancier qui possède sa
propre émission sur Canal chinue la
chaîne de Berlusconi sa cible les
magistrats son cœur de cible Antonio Di
Pietro à qui il reproche d'être allé
beaucoup trop
loin di piietro est un homme
fort qui prend la République démocratie
républain libéraux socialist et les
encul il tous mis dans le cul le
résultat a été un horrible accouchement
anal et de cet accouchement anal est
Berluscon Berluscon est le fils
de il sort du trou du cul de la Première
République la Première République c'est
vraiment bien fait
en T
examen au lendemain de l'opération
mainprpre l'Italie se réveille avec la
gueule de bois seul l'ancien Parti
communiste n'a pas été touché par le
scandale il n'a jamais été aussi fort
beaucoup s'en
inquiètent Berlusconi ne pouvait pas
accepter que le pays finisse entre les
mains de l'ancien Parti
communiste c'est quelque chose qu'il
n'arrivait pas
digérer dès le départ son slogan a été
sauit du
communisme et bien sûr il sait même si
c'est un homme profondément ignorant que
les communistes n'existent
plus mais il sait aussi que pour une
grande partie des Italiens qui sont
encore plus ignorants que lui la
mobilisation contre le communisme peut
fonctionner que pensait Berlusconi il
pensait qu'avec l'effondrement des
partis il pouvait créer un nouveau par
qui serait dirigé par unieur qui
s'appelle
mar
mais il lui a dit
non puis il a rencontré un autre grand
leader démocrate chrétien qui refuse lui
aussi c'était des espèces d'aristocrate
de la politique qui dis non à ce parvenu
qui était un riche c'est alors qu'il s
dit c'est moi qui le CAL
mère il m'a appelé et il m'a dit nous
devons monter notre propre parti et
comment on fait je ne sais pas mais tout
le monde le fait on va le faire nous
aussi
comment
faitil c'est très simple il transforme
la force de vente de son groupe de
publicité en
partie il transforme donc une entreprise
en une organisation
politique qui fait le travail moi je
voulais construire le prier parti
entreprise on l' repr mais c'est
exactement ce que nous
sous
alors j'ai commencé à organiser le
parti comment j'ai appelé les dirigeants
ou des employés de la boîte et je les ai
transformé en hommes de
parti connaisse toutes les entreprises
italien donc les meilleurs hommes on
peut dire on leur proposait de devenir
députés ou
sénateurs notre but était de trouver des
hommes qui n'avaient jamais fait de
politique devait être un des de
it il met aussi sur le devant de la
scène et bien quelques
personnalités du petit écran notamment
victorios Garbi qui est cette cet
historien d'art très provocateur très
excentrique j'ai toujours eu de la
sympathie pour lui comme on en a pour un
animal de
compagnie c'est une personne
intellectuellement plutôt modeste mais
il est habile et très rapide il a
d'ailleurs créé un parti qui a eu du
succès je n'avais aucune raison de lui
dire non
on l'a mise en place en 3 mois je
n'avais pas de secrétaire j'écrivais les
discours de Berlusconi je préparais le
programme je faisais la campagne
électorale et j'apparaissais à la
télé j'ai perdu 7 kg j'étais épuisé je
n'étais pas habitué à ce
rythme
l'Italia è il paese che am Qui ho le mie
RICI le mieeranze
mieiizzonti qui ho imparato da mio padre
dalla Vita il mio mestiere di
imprenditore qui ho anche appreso lae
per la
libertà ho scelto diendere in campo e di
occuparmi della cosa pubblica peré
voglio vivere in un
paeseberaleato DA forze immature et da
uomini legati a doio filo a un passato
politicamente
economicamente
fallimentareus nous sommes l'Italie
nouvelle contre la vieille Italie les
honnêes gens contre ceux qui ont
volé il demandit à tous les candidats de
certifier qu'il n Pasu
cette image était au centre de leur
préoccupation dit aux Italiens bien si
vous votez pour moi en 1994 et bien je
reproduirai au niveau du pays et dans
les affaires publiques le miracle que
j'ai réussi à accomplir lorsque j'étais
patron et donc c'est un homme nouveau
c'est un homme qui vient rompre les
codes traditionnel de la
politique c'est un homme très riche et
ça lui a permis de lancer un de ses
premiers slogans vu que je suis riche je
n'ai pas besoin de
voler les autres ont volé parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas d'argent moi j'en ai donc
Berlusconi ne vole pas il a déjà de
l'argent c'est ça la
clé Berlusconi le mégaloman qui fait
tout en grand compose même un hymne pour
son parti à chaque campagne électorale
il déballe orchestre et cœur d'opéra
orlio
noi
appenere a
te app la il applique à la politique les
mêmes recettes qu' la
télé il en fait un
spectacle la politique devient un
programme de
télévision un rêve une émotion
un un
slogan Berluscon totalement décomplexé
sans la moindre vergogne mobise tout son
empire médiatique au service de Sa
campagneord
pas seulement dans les mais dans les
émissions importantes du matin ou de
l'aprs-midi celle qui influence la
population dans un dessin animé on
pouvait voir le leader de la gauche
représenté en diable et Berlusconi en
angeet
berluszaalia
il Satana anche Satana TI
perocchto
à l'époque personne ne pense que
Berlusconi peut gagner certains
notamment raille ce parti en disant que
c'est un parti de plastique un parti en
plastique un parti qui n'a aucune chance
de de l'emporter notamment le Parti
communiste et convaincu qu'il va gagner
les élections assez
facilement
personne ne s'y attendait sauf
Berlusconi qui disait toujours il faut
qu'on soit le premier parti
d'Italie on venait tout juste de naître
on ne savait pas encore comment on
allait
s'appeler le nom Forza Italia on l'a
trouvé au dernier moment
mais lui disait il faut qu'on soit le
premier parti d'Italie et comme toujours
tout le monde se disait que ce mec était
fou mais ce fut le cas on a été élu le
premier parti d'Italie avec 22 % des
voix on était tous sidérés mais
Berlusconi lui n'était pas satisfait
seulement 22 % même pas un italien sur
trois a voté pour moi j'espérais au
moins 33 %
il était très déçu tout le monde était
euphorique et Berlusconi était
déçu la télévision berlusconienne qui
existait depuis 10 ans déjà peut-être
15 mass depuis un moment la population
italienne et faisit ainsi pénétrer
l'idéologie
berlusconienne donc la structure d'un
côté
et de l'autre il savait qu'il avait une
base électorale culturellement
prête la rencontre de ces deux
éléments et la sousévaluation de ce
qu'allait être
l'opposition ont fait son
triomphe je suis allé le voir et je lui
ai dit Sylvio si on arrive au pouvoir je
voudrais devenir ministre des Affaires
étrangères il m'a demandé pourquoi et je
lui ai dit que ministère était près de
chez moi et qu'il y avait un bon parking
foudroyé par la profondeur de ma
motivation il m'a nommé ministre des
Affaires
étrangère pour gouverner Berlusconi a
besoin d'Alli mais les deux compères
qu'il choisit sentent le souffre Dian
francopini est le leader du parti
néofasciste Umberto Bossi est
ouvertement populiste et
xénophobe pour l'opinion internationale
le cavali apparî alors comme celui qui
aura permis retour des fascistes au
pouvoir j'ai eu la tche difficile
d'aller expli que Mussini n'était pas de
retour en Italie que les militants
d'alliance nationale bien que
nostalgique n'étaent pas des
fascistes il arrive au pouvoir et là
commen les problèmes pour
berus
on disait que Berlusconi était entré en
politique parce que ses entreprises
allaient
mal et qu'en gagnant il aurait obtenu
les financements pour les assignir une
connerie quand Berlusconi décide de se
lancer en politique sa société va très
mal il existe des procès verbaux de
réunion entre Berluscon et s
directeursù onit clairement que la
invest aait une dette de 5000 milliards
de
les c'est vrai que l'entreprise avait
beaucoup de dettes mais les banques
continuaient à financer encore et encore
parce que c'était une planche
habillée faisait des milliards de
publicités et ça augmentait de manière
exponentielle ce n'est absolument pas
vrai qu'il est entré en politique pour
sauver la société
impossible
Berlusconi est aussi soupçonné d'être
entré en politique pour échapper à de
proba poursuitite
judiciaire sa réussite fulgurante
intrigue les magistrats d'utant qu'une
grande opacité entoure les comptes de
son
empire durant l'été 93 il y a une
perquisition dans la villa de
Berlusconi les policiers cher des prues
deis
on les conduit alors dans un petit
bureau vide avec juste un fax et une
machine pour détruire les papiers et on
leur
dit c'est ici que travaille
Berlusconi il demande où sont les
documents de la société et on leur
répond nous détruisons
tout pendant les 7 mois de gouvernement
il a eu plusieurs démêlé avec la
justice V pour une série de choses
pendant une convention contre le crime
organisé dans le monde les magistrats
lui ont envoyé un avis d'ouverture
d'enquête
judiciaire ce jour-là les magistrats
italiens humiliie Berlusconi don c'est
l'une des premières apparitions en tant
que chef d'État à un sommet
international son groupe ainsi que
d'autres groupes italiens étaient accusé
d'avoir versé des PO de vin à la police
financière pour éviter des contrôles
fiscaux je ne me souviens même plus de
ce que c'était mais c'était sans
importance ça a d'ailleurs débouché sur
un nonlieu mais l'effet médiatique a été
dévastateur pour Berlusconi mais aussi
pour
l'Italie continuare a dire Berlusconi
col Berlusconi il Cavaliere Nero
eccetera perché è una Menzogna totale e
io il diritto di reagire e di di dire di
invergognarsi a chi continua su questa
Strada perché la verà
si arriva alla soluz Berlusconi a été
acquitté mais son directeur financier a
été condamné pour avoir versé des pot de
vins il reste un point
d'interrogation le directeur versait-il
ses milliards à la police financière
avec son propre argent ou avec l'argent
du
groupe la justice n'a pas réussi à
établir si les ordres venaient de Silvio
Berlusconi ou de son frère
et comme il y a un doute il est normal
qu'il soit
acquitté les membres de la Ligue du Nord
se sont laissés influencer par
l'opposition et ils ont retiré leur
soutien à
Berlusconi la Ligue tombe et c'est tout
le gouvernement qui tombe et Berlusconi
est rentré chez
lui le premier gouvernement Berlusconi
n'aura tenu que 7 mois
les ennuis judiciires ne font que
commencer fraude fiscale corruption le
prince de la télé paillette va faire
l'objet de soupçons désormais bien plus
graves
encore il y a une une interrogation sur
la
provenance des
fonds qui ont permis à syvio Berlusconi
notamment d'investir d'investir
d'acheter des terrains de faire de de
construire cette ville nouvelle à la
périphérie de à la périphérie de de
Milan puis de racheter des télévisions
puis de développer son empire son empire
médiatique et donc il y a une
interrogation sur l'origine de ces fonds
et certains ont conclu que certains
observateurs certains analyes ont conclu
qu'en fait et bien une partie de ses
fonds proviendrait de l'argent du
recyclage de la mafia Berl vous imaginez
Berlusconi mafieux il est né dans le
nord de l'Italie pas en
Sicile en revanche un PROE i est bien
sicilien les juges le soupçonn d'être
l'ambassadeur deanostra auprès du
cavali cet homme est son plus proche
conseiller il est même l'un de ses
meilleurs amis
c'est c'est une calomnie inventé de
toute pièces c'est un procès politique
mon procès est politique rien de plus
rien
de 83 le nom de deloutri apparaissait
dans des articles consacrés à des boss
des parins de
Cosanostra l'homme qui représentait la
mafia selon les juges du moins jusqu'aux
années 80 pour les années suivantes le
procès est encore en cours c'était
Marcello
deloutri Marcello del loutri qui l'avouu
même fréquentait des mafieux avec qui il
avait de très bons rapports
amicaux il est par exemple l'homme qui
fait recruter par syvio berusconi un
garçon des tables en quelque sorte
victorioangano qui résidera dans la
villa de Silvio Berlusconi dans la
banlieu de Milan pendant plusieurs mois
et ce vitorioangano et bien en réalité
était un boss de Palerme un boss de la
mafia
palermitaine c'était quelqu'un que
j'avais connu à Palerme en
1974 plus tard cet homme est venu
travailler dans la résidence de
berluscony mais qu il
itit si je t'engage et que tu viens
travailler ici et quand dans 6 ans on
découvre que tu étais ami de la mafia
comment tu veux que je sache moi ça
c'est l'histoire de Berlusconi et ils
n'ont donc pas réussi à le coincer parce
que l'histoire de la mafia est basé sur
une figure qui certes a été mise en
examen plus tard mais à l'époque c'était
un homme quelconque si je voulais savoir
si tu étais mafieux il fallait que tu me
le
dises ils ont construit une usine à gaz
qui s'est embrasé quand on est entré en
politique on m' accusé d'avoir commis
des attentats accuser des choses les
plus
absurdes ce n'est pas vrai c'est tout ce
que je peux répondre ce n'est pas vrai
rien rien rien n'est vrai de tout cela
je ne peux pas me défendre
autrement
marcellori sera condamné à 7 ans de
prison pour complicité d'association
mafieuse une gif pour
Berlusconi qui pourant C de défendre son
ami con questi Signori e li ha
frequentati per commettere un qualsiasi
reato no non c'è una pena ha solo
frequent ma devono essere recuperati
alla societ
questiud lo
accano à Palerme capitale de la mafia
les juges accumulent les indices
troublants sur les liens supposés entre
le parti de Berlusconi et la pieuvre ces
liens Remon à la fin des enquêtes main
propres en
1993 quand le pays
it est Lamin et Berlon décide alors de
fonder son propre parti Forza
Italia il y avait un vide politique à
l'époque la mafia a profité de ce vide
pour tenter de jouer un rôle dans la
redistribution du
pouvoir la mafia essaie d'abord de
fonder son propre parti
politique
libre mais au dernier moment le chef de
la Maia rê et de se rallier à un nouveau
parti
politique c'est ainsi que par le plus
grand des hasards les antennes de Sicile
libre se transforme du jour au lendemain
en for
Italia en 1996 Berlusconi per les
élections face à un ostère professeur de
gauche Romano prod il passa les anné
suivant dans l'opposition c'est la
traversée du désert il est empétré dans
ses
procès en 2001 alors qu'il fait l'objet
de Neu inculpations différentes il se
jette à nouveau dans laarineine
électorale face à l'achornement
judiciaire il se cherche une nouvelle
légitimité par les
urnes Berlusconi est très brillant il a
une capacité à raconter des sottises
c'est incroyable
quand tu
VO
ce con
croise alla re ALC Gentile amicao
Amic il aprile ch alle PERG il
goverellara
reg difendere Libert ma anche la
possibilit di sospingere il nostro paese
verso un maggior benessere verso una
maggiore sicurezza verso una crescita
dell'economia che aiuti tutti a stare
meglio a questo fine ho rischiato e
rischio tutto avete visto e vedete
l'accanimento con cui si lotta contro di
me ma fiducia dianti Itali mi Forza
en 2001 il revient parce que les autres
étaient nuls le problème c'est que notre
classe politique est
àchiée en face de lui en 2001 et bien il
y a Francesco Rutelli Francesco Rutelli
et bien c'est un il a été le le maire de
Rome c'est un homme qui s'exprime très
bien qui a une capacité qui lui aussi en
quelque sorte incarne une politique à
l'américaine un peu
c'est on le présente comme le beau gosse
un petit peu c'est il se présente un peu
comme le Kennedy à
l'italienneitia
la Frances
Rell
l'itiaoni sur son terrain il réclame un
débat à la
télévision éta inqui parce que R était
homme il est beau il va
m'avoir Berlusconi a donc évité la
confrontation et avec une certaine
arrogance il ne le jugeait pas digne de
se confronter à
lui parce que j'ai à peu près 20 ans
moins que lui peut-être 20 CTIM de plus
et alors ça a été ça a été un avantage
qu'il pouvait pas se
permettre de soutenir et surtout il
était il
était 10 points 8 points 6 points 4
points tro points devant moi alors
c'était mieux pas affaiblir cette
position Berlusconi ignore routelli il
n'aime pas les débats et la
confrontation en parfait connaisseur de
la puissance télévisuelle il va faire un
véritable one man
show en 2001 il signera un contrat avec
les Italiens devant les les caméras pour
dire voilà je m'engage comme un
entrepreneur et si je ne réussis pas à
respecter ce contrat et bien vous
pourzer non scritto non scritto ma
segnato nella storia et nel destino si
impegna a realizzare nei 5 anni di
governo i seguenti obiettivi nel caso in
cui almeno quattro su questi cinque
traguardi
non foati raggiunti Silvio Berlusconi si
impegna formalmente e solennemente a non
ripresentare la propria candidatura alle
successive elezioni politiche in
fedeca
silvioatausconlusconus il il fait de la
poésie les autres parlent pour ne rien
ils ne font pas de ils sont ennuyeux
assez rapidement en 2001 Silvio
Berlusconi et bien se confronte à
nouveau comme en 1994 à la difficulté de
gérer un pays et notamment la difficulté
de le gérer comme il le souhaiterait
comme une entreprise il s'aperçoit assez
rapidement que il faut effectivement
passer par le Parlement ce qui est très
déplaisant pour lui et notamment il faut
négocier les lois et que il faut
discuter avec ses
alliés Berlusconi est comme ça il ne
peut pas avoir d'associés c'est pareil
avec ses alliés au
gouvernement les politiciens de
profession les vrai ceux qui sont nés
politiciens savent très bien dialoguer
avec les autres ils savent très bien
emballer faire des SAES des mayonnaises
avec tout le
monde non c'est un homme
direct rapid
bien sor va s'embourber dans les
affaires de la politique et puis et puis
en 5 ans et bien ça ne sera qu'une série
d'échec et notamment parce que syvusconi
aura aussi à faire avec avec les juges
avec les enquêtes qui se multiplient et
donc l'un de ces l'un de ces dossiers
prioritaires et bien ça sera la réforme
de la justice la bataille judiciaire une
réforme de la justice en fait qu'il
souhaite faire principalement à son
profit
Berlusconi a réussi à changer la loi sur
les faux bilans c'est un cas unique en
Europe il ainsi réussi à obtenir
l'annulation de deux ou TR procès qu'il
y avait contre lui voilà commentère
Berluscon Berlusconi n'a jamais cessé de
dire qu'il fallait réformer la justice
réformer la carrière des magistrats
séparer les carrières des juges
d'instruction et cell des
procureurs arriv à le faire mais ça a
déclenché la fureur de tout le monde
judiciaire au cours de ce 2è mandat les
plus farouches opposants à Berlusconi ne
sont pas ses adversaires politiques mais
les juges ils ne le lâchent pas ils
savent que Berlusconi au pouvoir fera
tout pour les
affaiblir on peut dire qu'il est
vraisemblable que ces juges ont mis en
avant les dossiers concernant syvio
Berlusconi et son empire et cela à un
moment où Sylvio Berlusconi cherch lui à
remettre en cause l'indépendance des
juges aujourd'hui si un juge t'accuse
d'avoir commis n'importe quel délit la
réponse est mais c'est un
complot autre fois on aurait dit oh mon
Dieu qu'est-ce que j'ai fait aujourd'hui
c'est un
complot ber tu parles par haine et
jalousie toute forme d'opposition est
interprétée comme de la
haine
le rapport du peuple aux institutions
publiques et à la
politique a complètement changé à cause
de
cette 5 ans après son grand numéro à la
télé Berlusconi n'a pas tenu ses
engagements va-til se retirer de la
politique comme il l'avait
promis c'est mal le
connaître
il se lance dans une nouvelle bataille
électorale en véritable idole des
Italiens che ha scelto di credere ancora
in questo sogno presidente siamo con
te meno male che Silvio
c'è Dillo così con quella Forza che ha
solamente chi è puro di mente presidente
siamo con
te meno male che SIO
c'è
per
te
m
siuskeni au bout de 5 ans se présente de
nouveau aux élections en 2006 avec un
bilan excessivement maigre et puis avec
le sentiment de la part des Italiens que
il a avant tout cherché à défendre ses
intérêts ses intérêts médiatiques
télévision se protéger des juges plutôt
qu'à faire les intérêts du
pays quand il gouverne il n'obtient pas
de
résultat à chaque fois qu'il a été au
gouvernement il n'a jamais été réélu aux
élections
suivantes il ne sait pas gouverner il
n'arrive pas à convaincre les
Italiens après une période au pouvoir il
perd les élections mais lorsquil n'est
pas au pouvoir c'est un très bon
combattant il crée à nouveau le
consensusutour de
lu il est bon quand il est dans
l'opposition et il sait mener les
campagnes
électorales en 2006 incapable de se
faire réélir il perd face à Romano
Prodi patiemment il attend son tour il
revient en grande force 2 ans plus tard
en
ce trè mandat est marqué par de nouveaux
scandales sur sa vie
privée un an à peine après sa victoire
la l'anniversaire d'une jeune
fille elle fêtait ses 18
ans sa femme jusqu'ici exemplaire et
discrète demande le divorce sur la place
publique
elle raconte alors la faiblesse de
Berlusconi pour les femmes c'est un
homme malade
elle évoque des vierges qui s'offrent au
dragon la presse va s'en emparer
notamment la pre d'opposition ne va plus
le lâcher et c'est à partir de là qu'il
va y avoir toute une succession de
révélation la salve suivante vient de
cette cgir elle a enregistré ses
rendez-vous secrets avec Silvio
Berlusconi les médias les diffusent le
scandale prend une ampleur
internationale Berlusconi n'a toujours
pensé qu'à
ça c'est presque un
hermaphrodite et où se trouve le sexe
féminin
ici photos
sulfureuse témoignage d'escor girl à
l'appuie qui affirme avoir été payé pour
coucher avec le président du Conseil
l'Italie et le monde découvre stupéfait
les désormais célèbres soirées
bunganga aux alures de véritables
orgis lorsqu'on commence à voir que
finalement il y a des dizaines et des
dizaines de femmes de jeunes femmes qui
sont
qui sont invités dans les soirées de
Berluscon il ont un discours terrible
pour Berluscon il y en a une qui dit
même on en a marre de ce vieux avec son
C
flasque pour les proches du président
les bungabunga ne serait que
d'inoffensive divertissement
sex quand on parle de ces fêtes des
Bua moi je n étais pas mais je sais
comment ça se
passe
spectacle il raconte ses blagues ses
histoires il
rigole il touche un peu mais toujours
avec beaucoup de
frîcheur les magistrats de Milan se
jette sur ces soirées ils y voi entre
autres CRIM la piste d'un réseau de
prostitution il ne recul devant aucun
moyen d'investigation toutes les
participantes au bunga bunga sont mises
sur écoute les conversations les plus
intimes F dans la
presse
ctivo iner iOO in una guerissima quando
vinco la guerra poi ti vedo eitto delle
bissim
dolzie
Berlusconi a été mis sur écoute vous
imaginez le Premier ministre mis sur
écoute mais c'est quoi ces services
secret vous imaginez la CIA ou le FBI
qui écoute les conversations
d'Obama il est tellement à la masse que
les services secrets ne travaillent pas
pour lui mais contre lui si les services
secrets travaillent pour le gouvernement
quelqu'un aurait dû lui dire attention
tu es mis sur écoute
je ne dis pas que ce qu'il a fait est
bien je dis juste que c'est un sujet qui
n'a aucune importance avec qui baiss
Kennedy avec qui baisse Clinton avec qui
ba mit on s'en
fout ce n'est pas un problème éthique ou
moral c'est un problème de sécurité
nationale tu fais rentrer chez toi 70 80
filles que personne ne connaît qui sont
pour la plupart des
escortes le confisque les téléphones
portables avec lesquels elles peuvent
enregistrer si je suis un service secret
étranger qui j'envoie chez
Berlusconi le chantage sexuel c'est la
stratégie de base des services
secrets c'est vraiment
déconcertant mon président du Conseil
s'est mis en position d'être victime de
chantage je suis très content pour lui
s'il s'est
amusé
on a tous essayé de l'arrêter de sa
femme à ses amis les plus
proches on a été un peu surpris par
toutes ces
femmes elles étaient partout dans les
avions
partout mais personne ne peut
l'arrêter il est difficile de l'arrêter
il te dit qu'est-ce que je fais de mal
je m'amuse je n'ai pas le droit de
m'amuser à mon
âge j'ai vécu ma vie je suis devenu
riche oui les payer ses filles mais pas
pour qu'elle se
prostitue pour qu'elle fasse le
show mais le meilleur est à venir
Berlusconi va totalement déraper c'était
à 1 an dans la nuit du 27 au 28 mai
2010 la police vient d'arrêter une jeune
Marocaine Ruby pour une banale dispute
avec sa
colocataire au commissariat le téléphone
sonne au bout du du fil syvio Berlusconi
les flics n'en reviennent pas le
président du Conseil demande à ce que la
jeune rouie soit libéré sur le champ
elle serait prétent-il la nièce du
président égyptien
Mbarak c'est le début de la
retentissante affaire du Ruby
gate et c'est là que la réalité a percé
ce monde imaginaire qu'il s'était créé
c'est comme Cendrillon il transforme les
citrouilles en
carrossse tant que l'homme de pouvoir
exerce son pouvoir dans la fable tout va
bien mais s'il en abuse dans la réalité
l'histoire se
brise pourquoi était-il aussi préoccupé
que cette fille soit retenue au
commissariat parce qu'elle était jeune
très
bavarde il avait peur qu'elle raconte la
vérité qu'elle avait été plusieurs fois
dans sa
Villette fois
tout alors qu'elle était mineure et
qu'en échange elle avait reçu de
l'argent pour
ça
it prostition n'est punie que dans un
seul cas lorsqu'elle concerne
une r
minoren
nouvelle au pour les juges milanis qui
n'ont jamais lâché Berlusconi le Robby
gate débouche sur son 17e
procès le président du Conseil est
accusé de prostitution sur mineur et
d'abus de pouvoir jamais il n'aura été
autant en
danger l'affaire
Ruby c'est le contraire de ce qu'on
croit la victime c'est Berluscon le vrai
déli c'est abus de faiblesse sur
personne
AB de vieux comme quand tu prends un
vieux pour son
héritage Rubby arrive papounet j'ai
besoin de 57000 € pour ouvrir un
magasin ok je te les donne ma belle
57000 € comment ça une une
prostituée tu l' vois chier tu ne la
vois plus elle elle l'appelle je suis au
commissariat tu m'aide ils m'ont pris en
train de voler que voulez-vous que ce
soit abus de faiblesse sur personne âgé
c'est ça le vrai dél
Bou
bouou novembre 2011 Berlusconi est cerné
ils sont des centaines de manifestants à
se rassembler devant son
palais et à ce momentlà ce n'est plus
seulement l'opinion publique italienne
qui va s'indigner de son comportement
mais aussi les partenaires européens qui
considèrent que l'Italie risque de faire
plonger
sera de plus en plus isolé avec minorité
avec une majorité au Parlement de plus
en plus réduite il est contraint de
démissionner il quitte sa résidence sous
les
insultes la
joie et en
musique
est de Beron pour
l'alie on se souviendra du permis à
point de l'interdiction de fumer dans
les endroits
publics de la loi sur les faux
bilans il n'a fait aucune réforme
importante qui a changé en mieux la vie
des
Italiens à part le permis à point
peut-être mais c'était une demande
européenne
Berlusconi a eu le mérite et il l'URA
probablement encore
longtemps le destin politique à la fois
extraordinaire et
tragique d'avoir légitimé
l'illégalité
l'immoralité le manque de respect des
institutions et des règles un éventail
qui dans les
détails monstrueux de sentiments négatif
en le bien
commun si bien qu'il nous faudra des
décennies pour digérer tout
ça février 2013 nouvelles élections
alors que tout le monde le dit fini
Berlusconi crée à nouveau la surprise il
réussit le tour de force de placer son
parti en position d'arbitre pour la
formation d'un nouveau
gouvernement aux dernières élections
Berlusconi a perdu 6 millions de voix
par rapport aux précédent
mais il
VO pour une pare des Italiens il reste
au-dessus de tout
soupçonsi qu'onaconte sur lui il cro
pas il pense que toutes ces critiques
sont une invention de magistrat
communistes
qui
invent
incarné c'est l'homme qui continue
toujours à refuser d'être dans le cadre
établi et ça c'est caractéristique d'une
bonne partie des Italiens qui se méfie
qui se méfie des règles de l'État qui
c'est la philosophie comme dit
l'écrivain Camilleri c'est la
philosophie du motorino la Vespa c'est
la philosophie de celui qui se fauile
entre entre les voitures et ça
Berlusconi continue d'incarner
ça
juin 2013 5 mois après les élections qui
marque son dernier retour en politique
c'est la somoire dans le procès du Ruby
gate il est condamné à 7 ans de
prison moi je suis très ami avec
Berlusconi il est très sympa pour boire
un
café tu écoutes ces 40 blagues et puis
il commence à chanter
CR il y a l'affaire
ru le problème de l'euro et
lui veent faire les
hér députés qui s'inent des lois de
merde et un couillon qui fait prendre P
ba voici gr
table le 31 juillet 2013 c'est le coup
fatal au terme de 20 ans de procédure la
Cour de cassation confirme une
condamnation à une peine de prison ferme
dans une affaire d'escroquerie et de
fraude
fiscale au total Berlusconi a été
condamné dans sa vie à 18 ans de peine
de prison cumulée il aura réussi
l'exploit de ne jamais passer une seule
nuit derrière les
barreaux loin d'être abattu il saisit la
Cour Européenne des Droits de h à terre
Berlusconi n'a toujours pas dit son
dernier
mote presidente siamo con
te
gente
questoamo con
te menoale silio
C Dillo COS con quella Forza che ha
solamenteamente chi è puro di mente
presidente siamo con
te meno male che SIO c'è presidente
questo è per
te meno male che
sign
entre Meuse et hauteemarne un
laboratoire unique en son genre est en
train de voir le jour tout ça en fait
s'organise autour de ces deux puits qui
sont les deux seuls moyens d'accès à
moin 48 m de de profondeur un projet de
stockage de déchets nucléaires de très
longue génération à terme ce sont des
milliers de tonnes de déchets hautement
radioactif qui seront enterrés ici
enquête sur un projet unique au monde
blage a pour vocation définitive d'être
fermé sans intervention
humaine déchets nucléaires 100000 ans
sous nos pieds demain à 1230 sur public
SNA
cancoun une station balnéaire du Mexique
située à 8000 km de la France devenu le
temple du tourisme de masse il y a 40
ans quou n'était pourtant qu'une plage
déserte aujourd'hui la côte caribéenne
est envahie par plusieurs centaines de
complexes hôteliers qui accueill chaque
année 12 millions de
visiteurs mais derrière cet
extraordinaire développement touristique
se cache un autre visage celui
d'employés marginalisés et d'une nature
sacrifié à 1 heure de la zone hôtelière
le quartier populaire numéro
240 Raquel a 27 ans elle est femme de
chambre elle vient de décrocher dans
de tu imag
loenta pens
estáadagadatoprte à prendre service elle
met toutes les chances de son côté car
les places sont ch danses
hôtelsquillarme tengo que ponerme los
colores del uniforme porque si me pongo
un
Rosado má fuerte entonces va
Raquel comme une grande partie des
employés n'a pas les moyens de vivre
dans le centre de
cancoun tous les matins les hôtels
affrent des bus qui viennent les
chercher dans ces quartiers
excentrés la jeune femme est Maya elle
est originaire du
yukatan ses parents se sont installé à
cancoun dans les années 80 pour profiter
de l'essort
touristique
femme de chambre plongeur serveur
balayeurs les employés Maya sont souvent
cantonnés à des postes peu
qualifiés dans les étages Raquel
commence une longue journée de travail
une parmi les plus intenses de l'année
car en ce mois de mars l'hôtel accueille
les Spring
Breakers
parmi eux
ance il est parisien et il est venu fait
ici la fin de ses examens avec quelques
amis il y a pas de
complication comment et je te PLA tu me
plais passons vacancesensemble dans
emble allons à la
chambreinité quoi on se connait même
pas
c'est le Spring Break un concept
américain qui a fait des émules dans le
monde
entier canadien australien espagnol
français se mélange dans une ambiance
survoltée ce qu'il viennent chercher ici
c'est surtout l'alcool à volonté 24 he
sur 24 et tous les excès sont
permis
man jeunes étudiants au sein de l'hôtel
où 14 bars et tr discothèques sont à le
disposition concepto de entretenimiento
del hotel casi comparar de alguna manera
con algo pue como un crucero en
tierra buo el objetivo del hotel con est
jves primeramente es queengan un
vacciones incblemente
inolv
cette côte des Caraïbes est aujourd'hui
l'un des sites touristiques les plus
visités au
monde pourtant ces plages étaient
totalement vierges dans les années 70
c'est le gouvernement qui a eu l'idée
ambitieuse d'en faire une station
balnéaire haut de gamme pour sortir le
pays de la crise économique un projet
financé en partie par la Banque
mondiale originalmente cancú estaba
destinado para un un centro turstico de
alto nivel pero en
1988 hubo un ciclón muy importante que
provocó un daño muy importante en las
instalaciones tanto de Hoteles como de
la ciudad las tarifas de los hoteles
disminuyeran 300 o 400 llegaran a caer
hasta 50 o
es así de de este huracán empiezan a
surgir nuevas
estrategias para ser
compistour nombreuses opportunités
professionnelles pour les employés des
hôtels
commeel mais cela signifie aussi des
conditions de travail
plusan las
habitaes cuando HAC pues depende si lo
hacen en la cama se cambia el colchón la
sában o sea todo literalmente se saca
todo vienen a hacer lo que en su ciudad
no
hacen cuento que entres en una
habitación dices hubo fiesta no porque
te encuentras varios como si fueran
Globos de colores ya tirados en el
suelo nunca había yo visto esta
clase de cosas no
en travaillant 6 jours sur 7 Raquel
touche environ 100 € par mois le salaire
minimum au Mexique mais elle n'a aucune
garantie de pouvoir renouveler ses
missions chaque contrat d'embauche est
temporaire puedo el lujo de
faltarab mi PAP y mi MAM dependen de
MnO
pendant que Raquel travaille les membres
de sa famille se relent pour s'occuper
de ces deux
enfants aujourd'hui c'est sa cousine
Landy qui va chercher sa fille aînée à
l'école public du
quartier yand a 7 ans elle est
scolarisée en
primaire sa mère voudrait qu'elle suive
des études qu'elle-même a dû interrompre
très
tôt
toda nuestra familia de nosotros somos
muy Unitas aquí vivimos todos y este es
que yo crecí con
ella y yo cuando era Niña mayira yo
igual la cuidaba a ver
aquí aquí acabas de escribir launa es
que ella se le complica mucho porque no
sabe
leer yo siento que porque desde Niña el
papá ha sido así que es un poco
separado yo me imagino que le afecta
mucho a
ella lo que más me gusta es que estemos
juntos como una
familia pues algo difícil porque no
tenemos estudios no tuvimos una Carrera
o algo así por eso no para nosotros es
algo
difícil una gran parte de esta población
de Cancún abocada al trabajo en el
turismo solamente puede aspirar a
meseros o a limpiar mesas o hacer
mucamas no hay una gran capacitación
para los
empleados también existe una
importante discriminación con los Mayas
por su aspecto físico no son personas
muy altas de
estatura de facciones no tan agradables
para otras
personas
à la nuit tombée quand les touristes
s'aventurent hors de leurs hôtels c'est
pour se retrouver entre eux dans les
nombreuses discothèques qui leur sont
dédié Toure me rapporterait plus de 12
milliards de dollars par an des revenus
qui profitent très peu aux
Mexicains la majorité des hôtels
appartient à des grands groupes
espagnols les leaders des offres all
inclusive alors que la fête ne fait que
commencer pour ces touristes les
derniers employés comme Raquel regagne
leur
banlieu de monde qui se croise S
Jama Raquel va pouvoir enfin profiter de
ses enfants qu'elle n'a pas vu depuis la
veille au
soir cuando yo descanso a
ve
CIN vez en cuando cocino
y en mis descansos mi MAM mayormente
cocina mi papá y mi mamá me apoyan
demasiado de vez en cuando apoya su papá
es muy
raros pero como yo le digo a mi mamá
pues no necesito de é para
salirante
même si le quartier n'est pas l'endroit
idéal pour élever des
enfantsot
laolsaitan LO
queas c'est ici dans ces quartiers
pauvres que le trafic de drogue
s'organise pour fournir en partie les
touristes de la zone
hôelière
mais cet autre visage de cancoun les
touristes ne le connaissent pas ils
restent confinés entre eux sur les
plages et dans les zones hôtelières là
où leur forfait tout inclu à partir de
1500 € la semaine leur permet de
consommer sans
limite pour rester sur l'hôtel et tout
est compris et et tout le service incl
mais par contre c'est vrai que du coup
on sort pas à l'extérieur pour pour voir
un peu qui se passe et du coup on fait
on fait pas trop marcher l'économie
vraiment mexicaine quoi mais bon c'est
pas grave c'est comme ça c'est juste ça
le petit côté négatif
à à
dans estos turistas
noramaconmica no Salen a consumir en la
ciudad de Cancún en la población donde
también hay restaurantes también hay
tiendas también hay comercios de todo de
todo índole turistas deciden mejor
quedarse en el hotel ahí comen ahí Beben
ahí viven el hotel te convierte en todo
es un restaurante es un hotel es una
tienda es un
transportista es
todo concurrencé par cette stratégie du
inclusive une grande partie des
commerces de la ville à
fermé rien qu'en 2013 250 restaurants
ont mis la clé sous la porte
dans les rues de cancoun les pancartes
de Ba ACD se
succèdentain
deireése feenida muy concurrida era una
Avenida que todos los clientes venían
prcticamente un turista viene a buscar
algo mexicano a buscar algo que ellos no
conocen yes la Verad es a en loal haa
tristeza Deo se haido cerrando poco
aquitoo la ver que ha so FeO para
nosros l'effondrement du commerce local
a supprimé un grand nombre
d'emplois et une partie de la population
s'est
paupérisé sur les 700000 habitants un
tiers des personnes vivraient dans une
grande précarité et les plus de 40 ans
sont souvent les premiers
touchés Marie et Lazaro les parents de
Raquel sont au chômage depuis de
nombreuses
années seul moyen pour eux de gagner un
peu d'argent la vente de
chips poures Maya arriv àcun plein
d'espoir le bilan est
am la
genteat SIAT
niachos
mi esposo tiene experiencia en el
trabajo trabajó como 7 años en el gran
oasis ya tiene apenas cumplió este 18 de
febrero cumplió 47 años entonces más
bien por la edad no le Dan el trabajo ya
no Med t sandali por favor te voy a dar
una Ngada
ehulation excl du secteur touristique
sans retraite ni protection sociale V du
système
D marie vient dans de FO les 15 JS
standentr
la pour optimiser les ventes son fils
l'aide dans son
travail c'est également le seul revenu
du
jeunomme
como equipo
Gan la gente está
consumiend mars
gradin
848 pues ahorita s vendí algo hace 15ías
es muy poca la venta pero hoy
sí maises faibles revenus ne permettent
pas Marie et son fils de voir plus loin
que le
lendemain le village natal de Raquel est
situé à 3h de route de
cancoun perdu est préservé dans la
campagne du
yukatan ici loin du tourisme de masse
les Mayas vivent du maïs et de
l'artisanat
Raquel ne peut pas y revenir aussi
souvent qu'elle le souhaiterait mais
aujourd'hui elle retrouve toute sa
famille dont son grand-père qui l'a en
partie
élevé
Lazaro est resté dans ce village sur
cette terre et a continué à parler le
Maya mais la tradition se perd dans la
fam laa
necesitao
as en Yucatán
ha español pur Maya habla pur Maya pero
nosotros pues aprendemos los dos
idiomas yo s lo
sé mucho gusto que ver ustedes que
venist a verme otra vez cuántos años has
visto ustedes
ya tiene un año que no vengo pues creo
que ya ya tardó mucho demasiado Noos que
aquí en tisimín Yucatán casi no hay
trabajo papi casi no hay sí hay trabajo
hay mucho trabajo pero es
doméstica doméstica que trabaja una casa
un
Rico pues no la Pagan bien sale se va en
Cancún o va en chomar O va otro lado
otros ciudades a buscar
trabajo mes y medio mes y medio y tu
hermanito
por eso Cho está trabajando no le DA un
peso a mi
mamá que está trabajando y le mantiene
soy
yo bueno está suave la vida enc dura la
vida así porque no puede trabajar uno
así
tranquilos héti de le culture
millénaire de dans campagnes isolées
même s'ils savent que c'est pour y mener
une vie très
modeste en la ciudad no puedes hacer
gallinas no puedes tener tu Cochino no
puedes ni hacer ni tu Huerta porque pues
si me preguntas dónde estoy cómoda aquí
o acá mejor acá porque pues aquí como es
un dejido yo me puedo Extender hasta
donde yo quiera planto mis plátanos ahí
porque hay Mucha tierra pero en las
grandes ciudades un poquitito que te
venda no puede
pagar cóo te diré si tiene aspiraciones
a tener una VDA mejor se tiene que
esforzar un poco
más sí los hombres hacen su Milpa y todo
pero no es suficiente porque pues tiene
que comprar la ropa de los niños cuando
se enferman lo tienen que llevar con el
doctor y pues ahorita no puede decir uno
que vende maíz porque si hay solo es
para comer no para vender y por eso se
busca
alternativas de
trabajo el gobierno no ha brindado el
apoyo
suficiente no nada más para poderlos
integrar al contexto de turismo sino
para su propio desarrollo en las comunid
esto es trabajar la tierra que tengan o
los animales que tengan o difundir su
cultura sus artesanías
ellos no tienen esa oportunidad muchas
veces tienen que caminar muchas horas o
tienen que trasladarse mucho tiempo
muchas horas hasta algunos
poblados con cierta afluencia ya sea
turística o de otra índole a vender sus
artesanías o lo que ellos
sur la côte le gouvernement intensifie
ses efforts dans le développement du
tourisme un secteur qui a pourtant des
impact irréversible sur
l'environnement car pour construire ces
complexes hôteliers une grande partie de
la mangrove a été détruite une
végétation pourtant
protégée
adal vquez
hré hô grand de la
mangveang
te
grrticamente Sonas
proteg
Mang Natur cont
ccléséqu
écosyst es impresionante ver que
hanado el canal natural toaví en octubre
venimos a unorrio
yoier erier
y las
construcciones están deteriorando tres
ecosistemas el de humedal O Manglar el
sistema de Duna y la Laguna
recifal el sistema ecológico va a verse
alterado porque la dinámica que existe
entre los dos Mundos el del mar y el del
sistema continental ya no van a poder
coexistir entonces va a haber un daño
ecolóico
constuc régulièrement guadaloup surv la
côte pour répertorier les zones les plus
menac
les laón
se al darn cuenta de los impactos que
vaniendo el desarrollo tanto turístico
como Urbano y la responsabilidad de
nosotros es este informar de qué zonas
tan vulnerables y si se están llevando a
cabo
desarrollo la
naturaleza tiene una capacidad
impresionante de absorber el impacto del
ser
humano pero si la humanidad sigue
deteriorando el ecosistema de no hacer
estudios en unos 50 60 años el color
Turquesa que vemos ahora en las playas
del Caribe va a
cambiar guadaloue véasquez archive et
metes ses photos sur internet qu'elle
puisse être consultable par
tous esta imagen es de abril del
2012 y por lo que vemos en la fotografía
también ya construyeron más edificios de
del lado norte de este Muelle
pero lo impactante en este caso es el
color del agua este ya no es el Azul
Turquesa que hemos visto a lo largo de
la Costa y esto puede ocurrir a largo
plazo o sea si no se toman las medidas
necesarias si no se Evita segir
construyendo en zonas
vulnerables podríamos terminar viendo un
color del agua parecido a
esto des scientifiques ne sont pas pris
en compte par les autorités les enjeux
économiques du tourisme sont bien trop
importants
no puedes construir tantos niveles de
piso no puedes construir tantos cuartos
de habitación no puedes construir calles
etcétera sin embargo muchos empresarios
muchos hoteleros construyen estos
Hoteles a pesar de las prohibiciones y
lamentablemente después obtienen un
permiso de
dudosa bueno en algunas ocasiones el
gobierno instala una multa si te pasaste
dos pisos o tres pisos eh niveles en en
tu construcción te voy a multar con a
veces ridículas multas de 20.000 o
30.000
pesos à 60 km au sud de cancoun dans la
station balère de Playa del Carmen
l'histoire semble se
répété face à la concurrence de
nouvelles destinations voisines comme le
Costa Rica
on continue de construire de nouveaux
complexes hôteliers et parfois même sur
la plage au milieu des vacanciers la
musique tentend difficilement de
camoufler les bruits des marteau
piiqueurs le tourisme de masse poussé à
l'extrême ce modèle touristique
pourra-t-il encore durer avant de
dévaster toute la côte
caribéen public S vous propose de
plonger dans le quotidien d'une famille
africaine au centre de la cour de la
maison familiale on croise des anciens
gardiens de l'ordre établi des jeunes
qui rêvent d'ailleurs moi je ve pas
rester
ici ça jamais de la vie desépouse au
relation plus ou moins
amical parafin samedi à 15h15 sur public
S
quel est le profil type d'un sénateur on
peut être élu sénateur des 24 ans et
l'âge moyen est de 62 ans contre 59 ans
à l'Assemblée nationale à 26 ans David
rachnil du Front national est le plus
jeune de l'hémicycle à 89 ans Paul vergz
le sénateur communiste de la Réunion et
lui le plus âgé aujourd'hui le Sénat
compte 87 sénatrices soit 25 % un
chiffre qui évolue peu malgré la loi sur
la parité les partis politiques ont
parfois choisi de multiplier les listes
plutôt que de constituer une liste avec
une alternance régulière entre candidats
et candidates très concrètement si par
exemple il y avait 5 sénateurs à élire
qu'un parti estimait avoir une chance de
remporter tr siège plutôt que de faire
une seule liste avec cinq candidats et
de voir les trois premiers donc avec au
minimum une femme élue ils ont préféré
ouvrir trois listes avec en premier de
liste à chaque fois un sénateur sortant
et de fait les électeurs ont en quelque
sorte validé ce choix politique puisque
dans les quelques départements où cette
méthode a été utilisée on a vu les têtes
de liste élu et le 2è euh de la liste ne
pas remporter de siège sénatorial un
sénateur ne touche pas de salaire mais
une indemnité fixe de 7100 € en cas de
cumule des mandats et c'est le cas pour
78 % des sénateurs l'indemnité est
plafonnée un sénateur ne peut pas
percevoir plus de 2750 € au titre de ses
mandats locaux soit une indemnité
maximale de
8270 €. à cette somme il faut ajouter
deux autres indemnités 7500 € pour la
rémunération des collaborateurs du
sénateur et 6400 € pour l'indemnité
représentative de frais de mandat c'est
cette dernière qui est parfois contestée
car elle n'est pas soumise à l'impôt sur
le revenu donc comme son nom l'indique
c'est une indemnité pour des frais de
mandat donc on va pas imposer des frais
qui consistent essentiellement à des
cotisations d'association à l'entretien
de la permanence des aviations à
déjeuner d'élus locaux et cetera donc ça
serait quand même paradoxal d'imposer
est fiscalement un sénateur ou un député
d'ailleurs sur des frais en revanche
qu'il faut vérifier c'est que
l'enveloppe qui lui est accordée est
utilisé effectivement à son métier de de
sénateur de parlementaire et que il
utilise pleinement cette cette indemnité
c'est ça la question enfin sachez que la
profession la plus représentée dans
l'hémicycle et professeur près d'un
sénateur sur quatre est enseignant les
cadres et les professions libérales sont
également bien représentés 23 % et
seulement deux sénateurs sont d'anciens
ouvriers